and welcome everybody to the i am not a gm
tournament it's grand mastermon hamilton joined
by national master james canty the third what's
up my man what's up bro i'm excited to commentate
with you man it's always an honor chilling with
the boys for the boys and we're here today with
i am not a gm i'm excited yeah and then people
should remember uh yourself uh james because you
had a match in this tournament and if i may say
so myself you put up a damn good performance and
a lot of people still remember that performance
against levy so so people should remember you and
hopefully they do but now we've got to bring your
talents up to the commentary booth with myself
let's remind people of the format for the i am
not a gm tournament there's the main bracket
it's single elimination knockout um important
to remember the time control there's a five
plus one portion a three plus one portion and
then a one plus one portion with varying times
that you're going to be playing for for those uh
time controls and of course the winner advances to
the next round of the bracket um as for the prizes
james i mean these these guys are these guys will
be playing for some cash which is nice to see
and they split that cash you know according
to the score of the match so even if you lose
the match then you could still be walking away
with a decent payday what do you think about you
know making sure that that as long as you score
some points you can still secure uh some cash
on the side hey man i think that's fair i think
that's fair of course chess.com did a great job
of of course doing the event and doing the prize
fun like that it's awesome man you're playing for
something and it's a lot of nerves there and lots
of uh we don't know what's going to happen so it's
it's definitely exciting and of course this payday
is always good right playing chess can never be
bad to get paid right absolutely with the 10 000
total prize fund the the i am not a gm tournament
keeps everybody everybody happy win or lose so
these players are playing for a lot of money
and let's remind people to bracket because
um a lot of matches have happened so far
and there's still a lot of matches to come
so we can see the the bracket shaping up there
today we are um handling the match of carissa yet
against teddy coleman um so that that match
you're gonna see today and that's gonna start
to shape the total bracket but james as you
look at that bracket there do any of the the
uh strike you as uh as maybe
some exciting ones coming up
uh exciting definitely costia costa actually
kosty is really strong one of my best friends
actually i'm really cool with him eric rosen
as well i mean he got e rose in today's match
like every time this match is on and no matter
what time of the day it's on i'm actually watching
it i may be laying in the bed sleeping but i am
watching it because this stuff is it doesn't get
better than this today yeah yeah i know this is
uh this is the prime time entertainment most of
the people or hopefully a lot of people in chat
right now maybe they're still feeling that buzz
james from the match the the armageddon match that
we just saw between jordan and annie to conclude
tata steel so if you guys still feeling that blitz
adrenaline then yeah you guys are on the perfect
channel because we got tons more blitz for you two
players who are going to be competing you see them
on screen there teddy coleman and carissa yep and
teddy has actually played in this format before
james did you catch the last i am not a gm um i
think who did he play did he play levy last time
or i can't remember didn't have the match
with levy okay i remember he did play levy
yeah and he won he won that match if oh i'm not
mistaken i don't remember that oh yeah he did he
played twice yeah he won that wow he actually did
quite well um in the tournament overall i think
he made it to the semi-finals um as i recall alina
and john i think made it uh maybe made it all the
way but it was at least those those three four in
the in the semi-finals finals so uh we know that
he's done super well in this format i am not a gm
despite the fact that you know his seating might
not be the highest overall so i think what people
need to remember about teddy's sort of a technical
solid player really really principled doesn't
like to go for anything too extravagant and when
things get a bit tactical it could get messy um
now what do you know about carissa yep because i
off the bat i would say that that's the exact
opposite style yeah that's the exact opposite i
know and carissa yep is i'm like a carissa you
know style all day my favorite players tal she
likes tactics swashbuckling chess i remember even
reading her report she uh beat her uh youngest
youngest female master ever actually to beat a
grandmaster actually i think she beat her first
gm at like maybe 10 i mean i think it was 10 or 11
right i just did the stats i was like wow 10 or 11
b to gm and like she's very tactical even they
say about her game her style is very creative just
like how we saw um you know van forest today or
in the whole you know tournament for tata steel so
i'm excited to see what happens is this opposite
styles gary kasparov karkov type thing you know
exactly and uh we're actually off
here as we see uh teddy and karissa
uh teddy with the white pieces to start
things off this is the five plus one portion
five minutes and then every time these players
make a move they'll gain one second on the clock
so it's actually not a lot of time and one
of the things that players constantly forget
is one second is barely enough time to
process the move and make one of your own
so we do see people flag in this format all the
time and straight off the bat we have a king's
indian defense oh king's indian what do you like
kingzine what about you i'm a ki i'm kid for life
that's how i feel at this point what about you
bro uh well i play d4 so i i get a lot of uh
king xenian against me so i'm very used to these
type of positions uh from the white side but uh
it sounds like we got two different perspectives
here which is which is perfect for the commentary
booth well actually okay so here in this king's
indian i'm not liking her position already
so she's this is this doesn't feel right but uh
of course we do have f5 coming in very quickly
how do you feel about white i'm actually going to
say white's white's doing excellent right now but
what about you yeah definitely the the h4 g5 like
pawn on g5 is generally very strong so uh if black
goes something like f5 or f6 uh white has to make
a choice are you going to take that guy on on f6
or you're just going to leave the pawn on g5 and
follow up with something like f3 instead um black
is going full queen side knight c5 maybe this
knight drops into b4 c6 could also open things
up but right now you might be surprised but teddy
i think he's really thinking about castling along
and a lot of people might be like whoa like why
would i ever castle long into black's attack but
surprisingly that's one of the main ideas in the
king's indian it's actually very sharp almost like
a yugoslav from uh the dragon type positions in
the sicilians cats and queen side sack sag mate
like bobby fischer there it is castle queenside
f4 moving to bishop queen h2 and do what we do
it's it's definitely going to be uh very scary
that move was bad though oh is that the pawn
it's just a central pawn and you can see the
the reaction there it's as that's a huge blunder
to start off this match and quickly taken by
carissa that is not a move that is very scary
uh now i mean especially now f5 my bishop can
swing into f5 the c file is open this is uh man
immediately change you cannot drop that pawn any
other pawn you might be able to give up but that
one that's going to be a big swing as you see
the engine already or the evaluation bar already
flipping into black's favor so what do you do
here now mod queenie one that feels garbage it
feels i might have to yeah it's tough because
you know queen queen c2 always seems to walk
into an eventual night before in the future
and you know bishop f5 sort of on that on that
diagonal to the queen so queen c2 doesn't
feel great queenie one might be necessary
but it's a hard move to play because yeah i mean
you're not used to being in this but she's just
gonna bring her knight back bishop at five five
oh my goodness bishop f5 and we live this is over
this feels like this is already over now of
course there's a lot of counter play left
these games can go you know either way sometimes
i know from personal experience i mean um you know
that's that stalemate i still have dreams
about that still made against levy so still
have nightmares about it but at the same time it
does happen guys you will see this kind of stuff
you know bishop f5 it can happen maybe i don't
know what do you even play here right now
a3 the thing the thing about carissa is you know i
was actually told that she was warming up for this
match like waiting for it to start by doing puzzle
rush puzzles so i feel like she's in the zone like
that she wasn't going to miss that pawn any day
of the week she's warmed up and i feel like maybe
teddy's a little bit rusty coming in maybe hasn't
got any warm-up games in because i i can say
firsthand my first games of the day always super
rusty so yeah that could be what we're seeing here
that's that's correct first games of the day are
kind of rusty especially if you're just starting
you haven't played any that's why it is good to
practice i always tell you know students about
like sports wise in every other sport even chess
outside of chess what do they do before they do
before they play they warm up doing layups
shooting you know basketball stretching
whatever sport that is chess is the same way you
definitely need to be warming up before you come
in here especially as a big boy match like
today yeah and uh we could see already a big
result for carissa game one coming away with a
win but she's got to prosecute this advantage i
don't mind the move e4 opening up that dark
square bishop maybe like queen e7 to e5 yeah
a4 a3 always get some some ideas there open up the
diagonal but we just saw a very committal decision
by teddy he just gave up his dark square bishop
and that's like that's pretty much a no-no in
the king's indian yeah actually that's correct
now my dark score bishop just like you said e4
very tempting here e4 looks good sometimes and
maybe even like bishop e6 and b5 yeah definitely
creative type chess here i even see knight b3
being a potential sacrifice at the right moment
so this is very fun and carissa is in her element
right now i think she should take this game here
with precision but of course she does have to stay
precise here and not allow counter play for teddy
yeah completely really like bishop e6 b5 i think
black can afford to be pretty reckless with the
position right now you can see that evaluation
bar is nearly nearly right at the end there so
that's a big big advantage for carissa and keep
in mind she's only up one pawn so if you have such
a big advantage like minus four that's almost
as if you're up a pawn and a piece right so if
she's only up a pawn that means her position
is so good it's almost like being up a piece
e4 played she says look i don't care if that can
be taken uh the exactly what i was talking about
a3 and that bishop opening up this is looking real
dangerous for teddy here very very scary here so
of course the eval bar switched a little bit
there i think because of the trailers going back
but uh the trade a3 happens now after b3 right
it's kind of uh it doesn't feel like i'm i'm that
bad anymore actually as white i feel like there's
definitely some misplay there something a little
a little bit sharper and this is five one she had
she has more time i think she should have spent a
little bit more time there to figure this one out
because white is starting to consolidate slightly
not enough basically i mean 95 and even
sacrificing on f6 can be good eventually but
he's defending he's defending right now and it's
not clear actually how she's going to crush this
and d6 is weak and a3 will be weak as well in an
in game but those bishops are monsters yeah one
thing to keep an eye on is if the queens trade
off the board really benefits teddy so if these
queens just disappeared right now there's a case
for uh for white even being potentially better
but with those queens on the board i i have a hard
time believing in the position following your plan
bishop e6 b5 i would just toss in there at some
point um b5 bishop c7 throw the whole sink at
him and then 1983 he played king d2 he's like yeah
we're running for the hills to the other side of
civilization so he is trying to get away here king
the d2 rookie a is we see a slight head shake from
teddy shake it out danny like yo i what did i do
here but it happens there's a lot of chests left
here lots of tesla so you know kind of getting the
kinks out warming up and maybe he'll play a better
game of course uh in the next games with white
yeah you said he's getting the kinks out but i
thought you said he's getting the king out warming
up his king is getting warmed up that's for sure
it's getting some uh getting some stretches and
we didn't think he would be going for a jog but
here it is it might even end up all the way on the
king's side at g2 so we'll see where he goes with
this knight i think he's got to at least finish
development knight f3 or knight e2 i'm waiting for
these moves to happen but he does not want to see
queen b2 jeez i mean look at the evaluation bars
losing his mind like what is like going crazy i
mean there's not even a like obvious move to make
his black right now because it's not too obvious
bishop f5 is not good bishop g4 of course not
bishop b6 is like you really really don't want to
go there so like what is it maybe it's b5 yeah i'm
really on the b5 train take that uh bishop b7 to
follow get your rook to the c file everything with
tempo really big fan of that also d5 can happen
after you go b5 to get that pawn out of the way
yeah that's correct b5 uh knight f3 here she's
getting low on time they both already got one
second increment there so uh she's trying to
figure this out i do understand yeah bishop d7
i understand i understand i have to develop in a
knight definitely a more modest approach bishop
d7 yeah bishop d7 okay back on carissa now yeah
you have to just play this b5 just don't even
think about it just play the move here it saves
time also teddy's almost under a minute here and
one second increment it seems like enough time but
especially in the time scrambles it's definitely
tough when you're when you're in a tough position
like this as well bishop c6 is on the board now
well bishop e4 is a threat and oh my goodness it's
unsurprising that teddy is going to lose material
at some point in this game i mean i've actually
been surprised he hasn't lost material yet
and another really annoying move to keep in mind
is if this rook moves like g1 or e1 sometimes
even just queen h2 and taking on f2 taking on h4
like all the pawns just fall in this position it's
really tough to hold yeah and actually bishop e4
is queen trap or it's close no it's just material
you can play queen c3 but i mean it's close to
being trout even moving the queen hits it again
so yeah like you said queen h2 yeah combining
that whole plan is just nasty it's just over from
there f4 yikes king in the center of the board
chilling around like a little box there queen and
knights and the king and that little square and
uh check is yikes playable followed by b4 though
teddy has a move there but yeah you make a
good point look at this this box here and no
pawns are left on the second rank to defend
interesting and he's holding like this is
miraculous this is a miraculous defense right
here i mean it's over but it's not over yet
i mean b4 look at this this man's holding over
but it's not over it's over but it's not africa
this is amazing here rook's hanging queens hanging
king's in the center this is the type of king's
indian defenses that we like to see i'm a big
fan of this kind of stuff now i know you're not
of course with the white pieces here oh i'm not
a fan of this is white nope don't sign me up far
away from this one right oh my goodness this
king by the way after something like rook c8
we see this crazy theme of the king just being
sandwiched between these two open files yikes
yikes wrong end of the sandwich here
rookie seven and rook a to ea doubling oh
yeah rick b man what a defense like he's defending
well he was defending this doesn't look oh he has
a move queen b5 what in the world no checks
yeah i mean what a defense and he's getting
closer on time it's a time scramble now wow
this is amazing to even make this a game um
that is not a move i can't believe this i mean
well actually i can i mean i i had a draw with
levy that same draw yeah i remember that yeah
wow it can't happen check check and we look
like we might be taking a perpetual here take
she says no perpetual but now the advantage is
gone he's out of this and she has two seconds on
the clock queen takes f4 king c2 queen e3 oh yeah
i guess that does work i think bishop e5 is nice
yeah you get the king of g7 and now white has no
checks i think white should lose this game yeah is
hanging and there's no way to checkmate that king
bam there it is uh-oh lev oh he did so now you
just trade snap snap wow he was doing great and
then he's like i can't believe this oh my goodness
right man that's game one over to carissa there
wow and that's that's a good one for the old heart
rate to start off and wow just as i was reeling
from the last game we get e4 to start off this
one she disrespecting him right now i mean she's
definitely disrespecting him and if she win this
game too like i'm about to check her repertoire
that's uh that's crazy she's just like b4 and
then don't and don't even think about it wow yep
some people might chalk that up to a mouse slip
but that's a that's a very real opening for those
wondering that is correct there are a couple
names but you know the orangutang is one of my
favorites my preferred uh names for this
opening b4 there yes and the polish as well
and i'm just looking at the the webcams as
well and i'm just looking at carissa she got
she got the hand on the cheek just around
yeah she's bored it's a great way to put it
hans was like this a lot uh shout out to hans
neiman a newly minted gm too hans was like that i
remember he was always just bored at the board and
it would be like a disrespectful board in a way
you're like man how are you bored but he's
so strong he's like i already know what i'm
doing like make a move bro hurry up right that's
how it is but it's at the same time like many
just players are like that but she's in the zone
it looks like she's almost sleeping right now
you know like how much talent is packed in that
brain that that it's uh she's just not worried
about the position she has under control and in
that last game um i think a lot of us might have
taken that draw but she she wanted more the whole
time she was looking for a way to not take that
draw because she was winning that whole game yeah
correct they're winning a whole game and of course
they're they're going to go back i'm sure down
in line but a different way because said he had
a terrible position there so he's going to he's
going to have to come up with something completely
different for the next one here now in this polis
position here these orangutans here aman i know
you're known for playing um many weird openings
and things like that jerome gambits and stuff like
that and uh what's my favorite the uh the england
gambit the england gambit that you play and the
queen sack and you miraculously beat a lot of
players with it guys don't try this at home chat
but please don't you can but you got to watch him
on videos first to see how you actually play it it
was actually miraculous i've seen him be gm's with
it and i'm like he's sacked the queen on like move
four and he wins the game still it's it's all
about you know sometimes you get the job done
but would i would i bring it out in a tournament
for cash you know that i'd have to i'd have to
question myself there i don't know if i would but
we see carissa bringing out b4 when everything's
on the line so that's it that's a different type
of confidence that's true that's a different type
of confidence right there yeah you absolutely are
right there he's like she's like b4 you don't see
any sweat on her at all she's not like shaking at
all i mean just stone cold killer here today she
with b4 as well i'm curious to see the other
openings that may happen um as well she's a big
favorite of cena was she played i think greg the
last time i think she played last time as well but
she played greg and she played they went through
a lot through the vienna vienna gambits back and
forth or something it's actually kind of a solid
position for teddy which is really much really
in his style i would say um h5 he's looking to
just tickle the idea of maybe playing h4 and if
white plays g4 the dark squares are a little bit
weaker in that position this bishop on v2 isn't
the best just because you got that pawn on c3 in
front of it which is why teddy is probably not
too interested in necessarily taking on b4 um
because maybe white just opens up the bishop yes
that's correct here actually and i am i'm a fan of
white's position but also black is pretty stable
solid as well figuring out where we're actually
going to put our king is a dilemma actually i'm
actually not sure where to castle to as white
hasn't castled either so plants for both sides
what do you think in here i'm on well i'm thinking
that white might be a little scared of king side
castle because of the potential bishop takes g3
and you just never know what the the repercussions
of you know f takes queen takes followed by some
wacky knight g4 move at the end could get wild so
um that that looks scary to me so i think carissa
is thinking twice about putting her king on the
king's side but on the queen side that looks
even scarier because black is a single move away
just piece play here but of course what do
you expect in a way as well starting with b4
you will have a wild position anyway especially
not doing a main line stuff against b4 usually
i think the mainline theory is e5 and letting them
capture on on e5 as you take the b4 pawn giving up
a center pawn for the wing pond just for rapid
development is the key in the polish orangutan
ideas and plans but here this is completely
different it's like some hybrid modified version
i have never seen before so they are definitely
playing some chess here today just regular chess
and this is exciting this is the type of chess
that i think carissa excels in and teddy is
he's got his work cut out for him because he
might get the advantage in some of these games but
he's going to have to work to protect
it knight g6 he sort of wants to play h4
g4 knight f4 again utilizing those dark
squares i think bishop e5 is probably not
the craziest move sometimes they play that even
though d4 is possible just to go back and say okay
you know you blocked your bishop now what yeah
yeah c4 is open that's nice e5 e5 is probably
too much right now right it's probably too much
because the d5 is hanging actually in that and
that's this um or yeah it's just getting the
rook over it looks looks a little risky i agree
um there's also like bishop takes g3 you know
queen takes g3 f1 f4 that's some real you might be
calculating that and then rook g1 and then knight
g4 no that can't be right that would be wild
but you have to calculate it and that's the
thing that's what they go hey there it is he
goes forward he's in on it he's like let's go we
are here guys we have been we've been praising
the attacking chest the aggressive chest from
carissa the tactics that she's been doing but
but what about teddy over there he's got
a one-two punch of his own bishop takes g3
the queen's coming down and it almost feels
like white's pieces are sidelined they're all
on the queen side and the action is now all on the
king side teddy is swinging right now he is like
i don't care about anything i'm going to throw
everything i have at you pawn takes g3 queen takes
it's on the board king f1 force and then we have
knight f4 or knight h4 um you're probably f4
yeah f4 feels like it just hits more
things um so i would go a knight f4 yeah
so now here's the critical moment is after rook to
g1 does knight g4 work or like do you play h4 but
then you do allow bishop takes f6 removing
one of the pieces and uh maybe even moving
well you can't move the bishop h3 is going to be
hanging in many cases so you might even have d4
as from white d4 swinging the queen back over for
defense yeah that's important that's important i
think there's there's a lot of potential ideas for
black like rook h6 h4 knight takes h3 um knight
g4 was mentioned queen e3 also hits this pawn
on e2 for well checkmated yeah not a bad start
hitting the knight so queen d1 might be forced
to hold everything but that's a very passive
move extremely passive here yeah there it is queen
d1 and black's winning like wow nice exactly your
idea of d4 to bring the queen over to defend is no
longer possible so now if i'm looking at hey how
does white you know unravel here i'm not seeing
a clear path i'm not even seeing it yeah and even
sometimes in some cases shutting the bishop out
completely like d4 just so you can play d4 just
to be able to shut the bishop out to be able to
use the knight on f6 because you really would
like to use a second you need another piece we
know this for a fact you can't do this with just
a queen and a knight and we would love to keep
pieces on but there is a elimination factor so
bishop takes off six so here's a criticism about
getting ahead of it not knight g4 uh ahead time
right now it works they they like it they like
it actually and then g3 rook h2 i mean this is
wow tau would be proud here this is oh and it's
played night james this is gonna this is gonna
be a fun one it's on the board big fella queenie
one knight it's two mate and we great so you can't
do queen e1 um you have to take this knight you
literally have to take this night there's no other
move to play you're already getting made it or you
take tonight after taking the night pawn takes he
sacked two pieces here teddy is hey look at him
in the camera see how close he is to the screen
yeah yeah because he knows he needs to calculate
a checkmate here because he's now down two pieces
yeah he's down two pieces here correct and he's
winning like that's crazy so if g3 queen e1
so we have g3 and rook h2 that's like the only
moves right yep those look like the main ones
here um rook h2 g3 trying to think of knight
h3 is also um an idea but it's looking a little
slow that's correct takes then we have to take
and then push h2 and then do all the extra work
don't have any checks yet this is a complicated
one this is very complicated look on g2 oh yeah
you can do that you can't even take that
oh my goodness that's an important thing
you can't even take it maybe wait
maybe you can king takes queen check
king f2 and then what well no king takes rook h2
oh my gosh stop don't do this to them this is the
puzzle rush victory this is a family channel
oman king takes rook h2 guys if we see that
oh my god but the thing is karissa's so
good at tactics i think she's probably
seeing that yeah and she moves the night
makes her own threat against the queen
what's it gonna be now if you leave the queen
there funny enough you actually can take back and
win the queen yourself but remember you started
this down two pieces you gotta be careful yeah
correct queen h3 and queen h3 at least keeps you
know discoveries alive with knight e3 being the
intention he plays queen g3 instead queen h3 would
be a little bit more direct but he did have that
uh where it takes g2 so probably not yeah queen g3
yeah yeah afterwards oh man look at the evaluation
bar it's saying you have two rooks and a piece
you have two rooks and a knight right now wow
two roxanna knight this is uh over but what's
the move it was not that one apparently the
thing is knight e3 bishop takes e3 covers f2 and
your queen is being hit so it's not the simplest
um dang it's equal now yikes that was really
not the move rick h2 because you have to throw
in a queen h3 basically you have to like
go knight takes e3 throw queen h3 in um
rook g2 take it and then take back on e3 so you
have to stay down a piece i think at this point
yeah that's correct teddy's mad too you see
him shake his head like oh bro what did i do
queen f3 stop it no no not queen f3 oh man this
hurts this hurts big blunder whoa wow 93 ouch
okay wonders left and right yeah queen side castle
maybe queen shy castle that's correct that would
be fun to see there how do we get the perspective
i guess king g7 e5 yeah e5 is good uh man this is
wild this is what's the time scramble you're going
to see everything this is not going to be accurate
chess here because there is a time scramble oh
my goodness oh my goodness get him off the board
whoa oh my gosh no oh my goodness what oh what
is this nonsense look at her smiling like oh
my goodness let me give it right back to him i'm
sorry i'm sorry teddy let me give that right back
to you check what are we looking there's so many
pieces that just changed hands there i can't even
keep track of that yeah king f3 and oh well that
pawn is gone that pawn is gone yeah what all of
a sudden oh my eddie is the favorite to win now
stop this you guys come on wait what's going on
i think that oh my goodness yes the time scrambles
the time scrambles you see this kind of chess guys
you see this guy all the time i don't know who's
going to win i have no idea we we think that you
think black's going to win anything black wins
by by time but that is a completely winning
position for black type that you don't expect
someone to mess up and it's tied one to one
in in this in this match right now james i
think we're just being treated to some super
fun attacking chess and we might see king's indian
again you know if the players were were you know
high adrenaline after that i mean there's
no breaks for them there's no breaks for us
that's right i'm excited man this is the type of
chess i wanted to see today i did not want to be
sitting here going to sleep on stream watching
the positional and uh the berlin wall and just
like uh very very uh slow chess i'm excited so
we're going to see some more back to the kid now
yep you know there's best sacrifices on e4 so
not now maybe it's not correct here but there's
a lot of peace sacrifices that i've seen on
e4 especially from some of the greats you
know analyzing and then playing f5 afterwards
but um we'll see what happens here maybe a5
maybe a5 yeah a5 is uh was actually seen in the
last game that they played in this line it's a
very typical idea to stop b4 basically saying look
my knight is going to stay there the whole game
and generally speaking although it happened last
game white does not want to play bishop take c5
that's something you generally want to
avoid that's such a valuable piece you
look at all the pawns that teddy's putting
on light squares it's really important to
maintain your dark square bishop so you don't
lose control of all these dark squares that
you're weakening with these pawn moves one
hundred percent actually here and this b4 is
expanding here we see white uh just having more
space this is the advantage that he goes with here
as black has much or has to play in swashbuckling
style to actually get some very sharp play on both
sides of the board here so white's going to try
to crush on the queen side i don't like his pawn
structure though i think something's like wrong
it feels like for white it feels like it's off or
loose yeah one of the things that teddy's actually
done in both games which uh i consider a mistake
is he continuously plays knight takes d5 and black
sort of has less space and the move knight takes
d5 always allows black to play knight takes d5 in
the last game there was knight takes e4 so it was
even worse he lost a pawn but even knight takes d5
is nice for black you just trade that piece f5 is
quicker to the punch than it was before if imagine
white has a knight on c3 and black has an eight
on f6 in this position i think i'd prefer that
as white the extraordinary the space that's 100
correct great uh great job the great observation
absolutely because here it not even thinks about
where does your king you know i guess you're
going to castle king side but safety for the king
is for white here is very very shaky actually
even though black's castle and the space that we
did have is not we used to have space especially
central space but we have activity for black b4
is a weak pawn still as well the c file is open
and we have a open king open king here queen h4
in many cases actually which is usually not
even an option in many kings indians but here
it's very tempting to even play queen h4 f5 and
just go yeah yeah i i like it and i think that
teddy is it might have to revisit his the white
pieces here against the king's indian because
i have not liked a single position that he's had
so far in this match you might need to change this
opening up yeah you might need to chase open
it up that's correct i understand that too
if you're not having great success with it it's
not you're not getting the positions you usually
are looking for you do have to have a secondary uh
opening or something like that you know that's one
thing correct here rook c8 is on the board i'm
loving black's position yeah oh bishop b5 at
least is a consideration but yeah just to stop the
castling but you know there are other ideas knight
g3 he wants to say look uh that f5 idea that you
had that's not happening anymore uh you're going
to lose all the light squares if you try that that
is correct actually many people would actually
still try to force it there i'm one of them so i
would like to calculate it okay maybe it doesn't
work all right because you really want to get f5
in and then when that happens you everything's
alive the center starts rolling the bishop
gets open because the g7 bishop is gross now
because we have played e5 and we need to get
this bishop active at some point in the game
and f5 is a great way to do it but queen e8
here so she might be actually preparing f5
usually that happens and yeah bishop a4 and
bishop b5 as well are pretty uh nice moves
yeah but and the bishop b5 move although it
was possible before white always had maybe
an a4 at their disposal so now bishop b5 bishop a4
there's ideas like bishop a4 rook c2 and just just
everything gets developed a lot nicer now that
you control both of these squares the knight on a6
eventually that needs to reroute i mean that
piece is not acceptable there if white plays a3
just locks that piece down for the whole game
we're gonna have to see like knight c7 knight b5
maybe knight to c3 or knight d4 i think that's
how black needs to activate correct also king
h8 in many lines here um just going for a decisive
king side attack king h8 with the intention of f5
and moving and maneuvering every single piece to
the king side so rook g8 at some point queen h5 if
you're allowed to queen e7 doubling on the g file
and using every single piece that you have so he's
going pawn hunting james what do you think of a
move like bishop a7 is that is that is that legal
is that a move uh well my hat says that's not a
move so we're going to go with that we're going
to go with that answer there every every fiber of
my being says that bishop a7 is too much it's just
too much he's asking for trouble that you know
that the last game his king was on d2 the whole
game and i feel like he's asking for trouble right
now because he's just not getting castle yeah i
mean come on you can't do this this is elementary
stuff guys now of course the the big boys and when
you get titles and things like that you know when
to break the rules so you can break rules here
but you shouldn't bend them to the point where you
know this is getting out of hand we took a bishop
upon on a7 it's completely out of the game now
hitting air basically it's nothing to do with his
bishop anymore and the king is still in the center
we have a rook on the seventh rank my system aaron
nimsu was like never give up the seventh and now
the seventh rank or the second rank here for white
is gone like that's ours and we're just gonna
reroute our pieces and have a great day here
actually even up on time as well it looks like
knight b5 knight d4 if that bishop takes on d4 uh
we've actually talked about already you don't want
to give up that dark square bishop in this opening
it's so important and you know is that the way
you treat your most important piece put it on a7 i
have my doubts knight b5 i like carissa's activity
here but i will say that teddy's position you know
is miles better than last time yeah definitely f5
is stopped he definitely has improved and now the
bishop on a4 kind of looks i mean it does look
silly it doesn't kind it is a very silly piece
but we do have many pieces crossing the the half
point here over into black white's territory
which is really good nice d4 also knight to c3 is
tempting you may have rook c1 in many cases there
but it's a very tempting move a2 is still hanging
as well grabbing a pawn back and yeah teddy's
definitely consolidating here playing on a side
that he's strongest on his pawn structure points
to the queen side so he's actually having some
pretty good play now actually afterwards c1 yeah
you might have to take on a2 and she does there
it is i think this is great if white goes rook
a1 to try to almost trap that bishop the problem
is black can always slide the knight into d4 and
the queen from e8 let's not forget is watching
over that bishop on a4 um yes correct and rook a3
britney knight really nice hitting that's a super
strong move knight c3 just wins here oh yikes gg
well maybe not gg well if we've learned
anything so far james it's never gg
right next to these guys yeah but it's definitely
a uh they type this in here i'm up in exchange so
yeah it's material right it's material no more
king side attack so yeah what do we do now like
what do you even do bishop e3 yeah bishop v3 bring
it back remember guys after the rook played to a3
there was actually nothing that teddy could do he
had to play queen e2 to guard his bishop so that
was just a good a good tactic by carissa that she
saw a couple moves ahead and g5 is played because
uh teddy doesn't want to see that bishop
go to h6 and suddenly get involved on the
dark squares uh he's trying to say look
that bishop's not playing in this game
ah yeah that bishop is not playing in this game
f5 f6 is a move queen b5 is on the board we trade
them and yeah trades help definitely chariots help
us having that exchange the heavy pieces are just
going to do what they do here even game so nothing
uh uh or even score so we still have more chess
here if he does go down in this game here but he
needs his definite like you said before he is you
got to think of this like the king's indian has
not worked twice here for you so we have to figure
out what to do before this becomes a big problem
later on in the in the match yeah because these
are these are big advantages for carissa at the
25 move mark you know that's that's barely the the
middle game in some positions so uh h5 played and
i think at some point uh the move f6 might work
out really nicely for carissa to just break that
structure hit the h4 pawn there's no way to defend
it um on top of that you could go the slow way
bishop f8 bishop v7 bishop d8 yeah and actually
time is uh not not existing for teddy here's 20
seconds on the clock here even though one second
increment it's still very hard to calculate this
position down in exchange here not the position we
wanted nerves are there and we're down so we might
as well just uh kind of he's going to play on
you should you have to play on here but he's down
a lot of time a lot of years yeah a minute and a
half more plus the advantage and carissa's got
this nice like the rooks aren't doubled but what
they're doing is each rook is controlling the
only open file in the position so she's got full
control right now there's no counter play for
teddy i mean he's trying to use his bishops to
get in there but it's just not working it's just
not working and the evaluation bar goes crazy here
bishop a4 we probably check is probably the right
move follow-up is where though uh that bishop
yeah bishop e7 f6 yeah i'm liking that bishop
b7 f6 looks fantastic just put the king up on g7
or h7 and that the pressure on the g5 pawn and h4
pawn i think that's the breakthrough that you need
correct yep f6 is it if f6 is the move here
there it is finally she got it off bishop takes
and that's everything g5 is coming bishop takes
h4 everything we need kg7 and we're good gg i
think this is nearing the end of the game nice
technique by carissa um teddy's still going and
we've seen how tricky he can be as the time gets
lower and lower it seems to almost get trickier
yeah she went rick c7 that rook c2 was just over
yeah rixie two i agree it just forces the trade
um now there's there's brooks that can
move around i think bishop takes g3 rook
uh bishop t takes c4 yeah that looks like a nice
conclusion there's almost mate especially because
it works on g1 but he has king h2 there's almost
mate it's like almost it's gotta be a rick jackson
yeah king h where is it wait where's the mate oh
he just resigned yeah of course two seconds on the
clock here too as well so tough game yep yep all
right and um i think there's actually yeah i was
gonna say i i think we are going to a break after
this game so players are going to pause after that
one and the adrenaline must be high right now
i mean what's your take on this match so far uh
james uh carissa teddy it's two to one for carissa
going into the break what should they be doing in
their in their break right now checking the lines
uh teddy needs to go back and and check everything
that he did in the in revamp and and talk to
himself in the mirror like hey you can do this you
can do this and switch out what he's doing with
d4 definitely there you go the motivational speech
necessary might have to look those kings indian
lines but we love the action so far very tactical
hope you guys are enjoying we'll be back with the
rest of the five plus one games right after this
and i hope you guys haven't uh gone anywhere
still here ready for the rest of the action in
the five plus one portion here uh the players
also got a break we got a deserved rest
and these have been some very very exciting and
tactical games so far james and i mean what more
could you ask for as a spectator right what
more could you ask for of course it's always
fun to see uh strong players play each other
and battle it out and especially when it's
you know something like your style i love exciting
chess like tactics and just wash buckling styles
of chess and and like noob kind of things right
and especially in this day and age so it's great
to see this kind of stuff it's great entertainment
not only for us but for the fans watching today
yeah this is going to be good i like to see
that um so far we've got a lot of games in
the king's indian and that always speaks to
a tactical game no matter what um carissa is
totally in her style and usually what happens
when a positional player and a tactical player
meet up is that not many of the
games end up being very positional
it's usually the tactical player that brings them
into their world that is correct i know that very
very well absolutely yes it's very fun uh to see
this kind of thing oh and they have moves on the
board e4 c5 so it is a society i think i think
this is from last time i'm not sure if they can go
underway i think this was the game they started
from last time i wonder actually are they going to
play the same moves now that's part of the mind
games you know like you play e4 c5 you both go
to a break and chris is thinking oh maybe i have
to check that sicilian you know and and teddy is
thinking oh he's playing e4 now okay so this is
something to think about for both players we're
both players yeah i'm sure they definitely went
and hit the the engine or real quick just to make
sure the lines are correct and checking things
and then get right back to the action here so
let's see what we have hopefully they did check
some lines though it's always good to be able to
do that yeah it's nice to have the brake that's
what the brake is for you obviously can't check
lines all the matches going but you certainly
can and you're encouraged to during these breaks
teddy just make sure to give full credit to him
tactically speaking because he had that absolutely
wild game where he launched every piece forward
for the attack uh it might have been the craziest
game of the match so far actually yeah that was
his and it was a decisive attack of course it's
harder and intense than time scrambles but man it
was nasty bishop takes g3 double p sacrifice and
almost delivering mate was great here so sicilian
defense here it looks like we have a special
fesnickoff here or the pelican oscar something
like that they did go for the sicilian so no
no funny business no tricks and uh this knight d5
move is is something we've seen quite a bit at the
top level of chess the i think magnus has been
uh employing this a lot world championship 2018
fabi this was uh definitely something he
was using here i even seen faruja use this
as well quite with the black beast is doing quite
well so are you familiar with this theory with why
you're d4 though right you're a d4 player yeah
yeah um but if i if there's a tournament that
you know i'll tune into it's always the world
championship so yeah um watching watching that
broadcast and hearing the top level commentary
on stuff like this you know you pick up a thing
or two um black does f5 move very typical um f3 is
because you know black often wants to just play e4
and stick the knight on e5 bishop f6 white on the
other hand uh really going for like bishop e3 b4
and c5 just expanding on the queen side because
both both guys are both players rather are playing
on their respective sides of the board it's going
to be b4 c5 for white and over here it's going
to be black launching sort of a pseudo kingside
attack that's correct a6 is actually a move this
and there it is a6 is usually played a little
earlier here in these fashion cough lines i've
played especially from night dwarfs and uh all
these other societies just getting uh of course
your your repertoire and your theory um so
you can get better at chess period from just
studying other openings here a6 though is nice
after knight c3 you do want to press forward a lot
of times with f4 in many cases moving the knight
into h4 and playing almost in the king's indian
attack style with g5 and g4 and king hey rook g8
especially if you're a tactical player this is
definitely very appealing um for this it's because
if white gets this attack on the queen side it's
it's almost over it's almost over d6 is very weak
and then that's going to follow with c5 or c5 d6
thing it's not fun not fun if you're not attacking
it's not fun if you're getting swung on right
you're getting hit back that's not exactly and one
move we're going to have to see here is bishop f2
because there's just no way black can get away
with trading those dark square bishops like that
after queen takes g5 knight f4 there'd be way
too many threats um keep in mind after knight
f4 knight takes e2 uh that c4 pawn suddenly lacks
a lot of defenders right they take d2 there might
be b5 to follow there might be just queen c7 yeah
be very careful you're not dropping that yes rick
c1 is actually a blunder it looks like that would
be a move but rick c1 immediately loses tonight
takes e2 and why would you want to play rook c1
well you want to defend upon as a monster here
queen b3 yikes that seems like that should be off
but maybe it works they do prefer black a little
bit here i mean who wouldn't pieces look great
weak c pawn but what do you do how about queen e8
it's like the same idea as last game he's covering
the a4 square and you might also go queen g6 and
set up some funny business on g2 oh yes i love
this idea queenie a queen g6 and uh delivering
mate why not queen h3 is always like this is fun
this is the fun type of chess here and teddy is
definitely showing a different style of course
with the black pieces but with white he definitely
is uh he needs to get better with that d4 we have
to see some better d4 from teddy today if he's
going to keep playing that e4 interesting before
so like that too much pawn takes e4 trying to see
what the idea is is um yeah what are you trying
to do because we always have bishop d4 right yeah
bishop d4 is always following so sometimes the
idea when the knight is on g6 is you play e4 and
after they take you play f4 and then you put your
knight on e5 and go for a quick f3 but now that
the knight is already on f4 i don't think that's
the the plan at all i think it's more like look
pawn takes just pawn takes back and the bishop is
getting opened up i can just take that pawn on e4
i'm always into like i'm gonna take your material
if it's that you took bishops right of course
knight let's not drop a piece please okay let's
say you said you're into that yeah just yeah you
know hey i'm gonna take it anyway okay exactly you
got to show me put the piece hanging there so pawn
takes takes so then what do we do bishop d4 yeah
it has to be probably just bishop d4 afterwards
rookie one is definitely a an alternative bishop
d4 yep there it is pawn takes and then rook e1 or
bishop d yeah ricky one looks uh reasonable
there there's always like knight d3 in the
position honestly um just to get rid of that dark
square bishop i don't know if it's worth it though
um you know potentially at the the cost but with
rookie one knight d3 looks looks pretty reasonable
weak pawn on e4 yeah it's very in 93 yeah but
of course as uh as the pawn advances the more
it advances the more it becomes weaker it becomes
very weak as it advances by itself and there is
rookie one now rookie one is on the board e4 is
coming yeah there's a few ways to play i mean you
can just obviously take that bishop is completely
reasonable um knight d3 uh as well i i really
want to get the queen out to like g i was just
about to say that like can we do queen e8 anyway
anyway but bishop d well bishop d3 takes with
the knight so you have to be careful because we
are just immediately hopping into an x-ray after
rookie one so rookie one i mean maybe something
bishop f3 like that might work well that's kind
of annoying queen e8 bishop three so um yeah
i want to play that so bad though sometimes
you just do it and hope for the best
but in this situation though you know it's a lot
on the line here sometimes she's also up a game
you know or he's he's down the game yeah so you
can't be you can't be too risky here and risk a
two-point lead sometimes because that's hard to
come back from even in in going back and forth
when you're going back and forth like this one
game i win game you win a game the person that
goes up to usually can get that streak and that
momentum and that could be over from there so
it's definitely detrimental bishop h3 is on the
board oh my goodness he says let's go for it
what is that god messing around bishop h3
he's unpacked a lot of peace sacrifices in
this match so far bishop h3 well that pawn
is loose and let's say you take it yeah
takes yeah knight takes back king up to g2 and
then what i think i think it's just takes bishop
h4 oh hold on that's in there teddy's strong
strong okay teddy that was nice pawn takes knight
takes kg2 snap on f2 snap on f2 twice bishop h4
check and king f1 and then maybe queen f6 oh my
goodness that is gross exactly this is the family
there are kids watching this one that's gross
and if there are kids watching take note of that
tactic right there bishop h3 looks like a big
time move uh now that i'm looking at taking on h3
it looks lost so i'm looking at knight takes e4
as like uh you know i just need to make
this move there it is yeah she goes forward
she goes for it yeah and bishop takes g2 is the
critical moment i'm assuming has to be g2 and
knight takes g5 is well can you
do that and then play bishop g3
definitely can um i guess you just at that point
you you would just play knight takes e2 and or
bishop takes f1 one of those moves bishop g4
does look like a a good move to at least survive
um in this position there's no knight
takes e2 anymore there's no knight h3
right yeah there's no not h3 anymore uh definitely
loving black's position of course here but white
is having some dynamic counter play with knight
g5 and bishop e6 coming in we have some defenses
we do have some defenses where we are we i think
it's inevitable that exchange is going to be lost
but it figures out we have to figure out kind
of how what's the best way to do that what's
the best way to actually give up this exchange
without losing too much and playing inaccurate
here because black is already you know slightly
better here especially with the eval bar going
in that way but these are humans here and we have
to try to figure this out but there are chances
though for carissa but definitely uh teddy's
doing a great job he needs to speed up though so
the rook is hanging um if bishop takes f1 bishop
takes c8 for example i i'm not so sure about that
like queen takes c8 and the queen gets into g4 i
thought teddy should just gone for it there but
he really wants that material he wants to take on
f1 but i'm not convinced after you take on f1 rook
takes bishop g3 for white you got c5 coming in
yeah that's great counter play compensation is
some big compensation here for white as it's back
to equal now rook pa he just wanted to keep that
material here and there is bishop g3 and you kind
of have to go for this the bishop is looking crazy
you're not going to take on e4 so you you
literally have to take on f1 there's like
probably no other move um yeah take on f1 and then
what's the follow-up but teddy is losing critical
time here critical time right now he's down i
mean 30 seconds here basically it's not a it's
not that fun to be down this much time messing up
disadvantage here and again he's down he's down
one game this could be the second game which could
you know lead to decisive results in tilting yep
and rook beat e8 is a move that he's looking to
play as soon as possible um there's also c5 ideas
by carissa but she's got to sort out this knight
problem first knight's being attacked knight takes
g5 obviously move rookie one looks reasonable
does have some discovered attacks or you could
just go knight back but i don't like necessarily
allowing knight e2 um yeah that's correct here huh
it's a tough one very tough and she's now yeah she
spent a long a lot of time here because though
this was a critic this is a critical moment
and now the next hit again i mean rook bde-8 is an
easy move for teddy to play in about two seconds
he makes the threat all over again yeah yikes
look at the time now it's completely flipped now
it's under 20 seconds for carissa can you just
play rookie one what's wrong with rookie one
well i guess it it looks like you're almost
walking into a pin but that bishop on g3 is
just holding it right because i mean you gotta
make a move here she's out of time knight f2
and the time is switching and it immediately
jumps into black's favor so what's the move
here must be something nasty here but i don't
see it it's not very clear yeah i i'm looking
at knight e2 as a really strong move h5 looks good
because there's no e6 okay snapping a bishop off
yeah and i think that's for clean h4 take on
yeah taking two for you i think she didn't
want to or he didn't want to allow rather bishop
e6 it's just one of those annoying looking moves
teddy's feeling it here he's seeing
yeah he's feeling it come on teddy he's
he's going to try to pull this one out here queen
takes g4 nice defense king g2 yep there it is
i'm about to say a triple on the file with a smile
oh no that probably can't be right snap okay now
tr oh yikes gg oh bishop takes f2 is the wrong one
it had to be broken um i mean the time taking down
playing the the best move under time pressure and
we're talking about single seconds here is you
know that's just a difficult task and that works
for teddy in his favor so now it's back to even so
he can sigh you know i can breathe okay it's not
a two-point lead we're even now and now we can go
back to where we are and look at that he switched
it up you see that good job good job teddy he
did not want to go back into the king's indian
and i have to say good job because it's so hard
as a chess player you have your openings you're
stubborn you studied them that's what you know
best but for some reason or another it's just not
working in a match and to switch up this early on
in the match i think that that's just the maturity
yes that's just the maturity there absolutely not
actually i love this position already here did
was did this start as a job in london or something
it looks like yeah just just the london moves
and he switched it up and then he switched
three right now we have a e4 on the board here
more of a philadelphia modern type position
almost king zidion style still as well i
like white positions in here just because
of uh knight d2 knight c4 being a critical
idea because the d6 square is extremely weak
yeah bishop e3 i mean d6 is is weak you could even
consider playing queen d6 in some positions but
um very solid approach by teddy got h3 to stop
knight g4 keep that bishop safe on e3 and you know
at some point you might see white throw the a pawn
up the board um a45 looks like a a decent start
here also queen d3 um to c4 is another uh common
maneuver and we do see teddy start with that a
pawn yeah start with that and this is actually a
perk now like or pierce is what they say we know
in america we say perk all the time so they're
going to kill me in the chat you know yeah
it's pure it's pronounced beards right you know
but it's a it's a it's it is a perk or appears
here now and actually in these positions knight
c4 yeah this is a pretty tight position it's
honestly still theory to say the least so it's
equal chances for both sides not familiar with
the queen e1 lines i think black is now slightly
better here because there's a critical line that
you actually have to do to play this correctly is
why well you you're giving a lot of credit there
by saying you're not familiar with the queen e1
line i i don't know if it's even a line at all
so that was very diplomatic of you
there i'm not familiar with this line
uh i don't know about a line but queenie one
is looking like the absolute wrong energy all
around yeah it's usually not right but i mean hey
you know we could make it work it's not that bad
usually the queen likes to sit on d2 and e2 those
are the critical squares from uh pure studies but
that's usually oh my yo wow this this is why
we came to play today like bishop takes h3
this is why queen e1 is not a line this is
not a move right that's not a line oh my
goodness there's no guys already there's
tactics on the board yes bishop takes h3
okay so take so i guess she's going to take on
h3 now with a critical i mean pawn structure it's
absolutely h5 and white is in serious trouble
serious trouble absolutely gross position for
white now i would be ashamed now um because i'm an
e4 player so i know when i play i'm e4 for life so
when i play e4 we get a pierce defense this is
not what i wanted at all the furthest away from
it when you play the pierce defense or against
it knight h5 is an excellent move followed by
moves like f5 and even trying to get a bishop on
e5 after kicking this knight it's really annoying
on c4 yeah like knight h5 queen g5 knight f4 or
queen h4 these are all like game-winning tactics
knight h5 is really important when we live i
mean even queen h4a like you said queen g5 like
sometimes even having work lifts but it's
difficult to lift in here we would love
to get a rook lift in but like that seems almost
impossible to do you don't actually need to though
c3 is hanging so like your queen has to stay on e1
like man tough game here tough game but at least
it's dead even it's like they're starting over so
okay you know take take stock don't do this again
and then keep going forward just like he's
doing right he's not playing he didn't play
d4 or the king's indian no more this one's not
working cool we're to switch it up until we find
something that does work is because they have so
much time here today uh i'm looking at like b5
uh you know take stakes and then b4 maybe if you
really want to take advantage of that pin he goes
uh or she goes rather different direction with uh
bishop h6 oh yeah bishop h6 yeah bishop a6 hitting
f4 okay that can be right but i mean yeah my queen
is getting in there like queen g5 and we live
close you like it queen g5 the only thing is you
almost wish your bishop could go to f4 and then
queen g5 so your bishop's actually participating
in the attack as well very nice i like that bishop
f4 first and then i like that i like it looks
like the order yeah my my idea actually was
queen g5 bishop f8 but actually um that is the
same thing it's just better i like bishop f4 more
because it cuts off the h2 square which is what
i was going for that's why we was playing bishop
f8 to play bishop uh oh actually no that doesn't
well you were setting it up the long way with you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so bishop f4 though
is just more direct and then after queen check
we got knight g3 and gg so that's like over
yeah and keep in mind an important principle
uh for the people watching to understand
is that when you when you have a position
with opposite bishops and it's an end game we
always say that it's usually a draw because
you know these bishops just never intersect
each other they they always dodge each other
on opposite colors but when the queens are on
the board and there's an attack in full force
that means that if i'm attacking and i have a
dark square bishop it's so hard for the other
player to defend because just like in an end
game they don't touch each other the same thing
happens when you're defending all of a sudden
your light squared bishop can't defend anything
that that dark square bishop is attacking
yeah that's correct yeah it's actually a 100
um a good position for the person attacking so
opposite color bishops does not mean it's a draw
it does mean though that they can't help in
the defense at all as you see the bishop on d3
is nothing but a pawn here it's a big pawn tall
pawn whatever you want to call it here but it's
not a piece right now so it's uh it's like you're
playing down a piece actually black plays bishop
g7 i guess just tying the position down so the
interesting thing is that knight on c4 is the glue
it's holding the position together you move
that knight bishop you're live and you can
you can resign yeah so i like to move rook b1 it
gets out of the pin on this pawn and it stops b5
most importantly critical critical because b5 yeah
that that is the glue he says that's 100 correct
because 95 is uh it's covering e5 the knight
is covering e5 that bishop check is devastating
you might even have to play e5 in some
cases because you do have to defend it
but it's scary like this is all losing but look
at the evaluation bar like that's very deceiving
looks are very deceiving like this is oh it's
equal equal where equal what what kind of math
are you doing like that's yeah and there's only
a single move that saves the position to around
an equal evaluation and basically all the moves
were around stopping b5 so rook b1 was a move
queen b1 was maybe a move as a ridiculous like uh
queen g3 would be blundered there but the point is
if b5 happened to me the game is the game is like
over right i don't see why b5 is not crushing here
exactly yeah b5 is gg right i mean is there
an equal or stronger threat maybe rook g1
i think i mean because that's why the engine thing
was minus three so yeah it's got to be b5 yeah b5
rook g1 is probably g1 just like yeah there
it is just to throw it in and i think queen f4
is reasonable enough the knight's gonna end up
there there's like bishop hanging nice hanging
pawn right actually yeah i wasn't into trading
as well because i like keeping pieces on because
i'm just trying to mate you all the time if i
can keep yeah totally fair you know i'm trying to
make you i don't want to trade anything but yes uh
trading would actually be an easier win technical
win there as you said the knight in the bishop's
hanging the pawns hanging on d3 and c3 i mean it's
just an easy in-game win there are no problems
there bishop takes c3 with bishop b5 and we live
gg everywhere all the diagonals are gross for for
white especially the dark probably the main thing
in teddy's favor right now is you know there's
there's ideas once you save the rook queen f3 that
knight is hanging on h5 and most importantly the
time situation he does have like almost an extra
minute and you can never underestimate what that
does to carissa she has to play that that ever so
much faster and she might blunder in time pressure
yes correct the time pressure is is on carissa yep
has actually been showing she hasn't uh she
hasn't crumbled pretty like it wasn't drastic
mistakes she didn't make that one mistake but
they both did she you know he hung the rook or
she hung the rook and then it was a piece before
that so it was just back and forth generosity
but uh this definitely is a sharp play as we
have a 40 seconds for carissa it is enough time
as long as she just keeps thinking here play easy
moves bishop e5 knight to g3 coming maybe rook c8
he's trying to actually uh i think he's a fan
of rook a6 um maybe the engine isn't a big fan
but it kind of stops black's pawns and also
eyeballs this pawn on g6 so i think that's
a good creative move and i also like queen f3 may
as well make that threat of queen 88 might as well
yeah actually teddy's very tricky slippery
player very tricky as we've seen him sacking
and doing all kinds of stuff don't give it don't
just give it to him here queen f3 queen takes h5
is a possibility with it doesn't work yet
the queen is too close on e7 for defense
to be able to sack everything on g6 but
you're thinking about it i was thinking
i was definitely that's the first thing i'm
thinking about usually my second but if i
it doesn't work and especially e3's hanging as
well carissa yip is down so much time here whoa
yeah that's pretty that's tough you can't be down
that much time now this is definitely probably um
i mean maybe drawn or she might lose this based
off her time to be honest absolutely queen takes
e3 and needs to be played very quickly by
teddy a7 is going to be hanging after that
queen h6 ideas look at teddy bounce back here look
at teddy bounce back here so now we just probably
keep threats up what's the best move maybe rich
g4 i really don't want to play that yeah he plays
it though but i really didn't want to play that
cool i didn't want to trade really so now queen h6
yeah queen h6 looks reasonable um as you said
pressure is all on g6 right but the real threat is
you know there's also rook h4 ideas um quincy
one yeah knight p6 so she's like very scared
that was a great defense though yeah she
played knight b6 because that rook was
nasty i was trying to mate you and she stops
it no more mates now you probably take on b5
i'm trying to uh well maybe i just take on
b5 why not she got two seconds on the clock
queen a1 oh look at this look at look at the
change up here on us now equal well bring the
rook everything is loose now f1 okay five eight
seven five oh a7 is hanging oh and as soon as
rook f3 happens rick f3 man should get right in
there rick f3 is that right guys there it is it's
on the board knight d7 how do you finish this
off no moves he hats knight d5 is is a huge move
coming up six seconds oh my goodness look at
him shaking his head okay six check king h1 oh
thank you so much everything must go sale and
have a nice day queen f6 yep that's over bishop
takes g6 why not don't even think twice about it
give me everything six wow gg man that was crazy
holy smokes wow teddy was not supposed to win
that game and i i should like jump back to that
game for just a quick second there were a lot of
tactics that just zoomed by at the end um because
yeah what was that first of all the
main tactic that i saw was after king g7
it looked like rook takes b6 yeah called
like queen a1 and rook takes 88. it was
the first one yeah yeah i saw sneak
by there yeah um and then after that
it was the knight f6 move by black which was
the the the big mistake of the game and then
the game was over after that so we'll get back
to the current game but man there were tactics
flying left right and center carissa ends up
uh the worst end of that teddy takes the lead
the first time in this match i believe three to
two yeah that's correct and now he feels i'm sure
he feels great about that game now he's trying to
close it out and then he say close it out is in
the no one's had a two game league yet sometimes
and usually when you do have that two-game lead
psychology for the player down to usually kicks
in as they're like i can't lose another one and
we're scoring down three so you take extra risk
and it's just so many things that happen one being
down one game is fine being down two games though
is definitely a huge difference and you need to
make sure that we stop the bleeding to say the
least in that sense queen to c7 is on the board
so what what was this opening actually um it
looks like so we'll just refresh the moves um
quickly so people can see how we got here but it
looks like a very similar ready style uh position
that we have seen in the past from carissa so she
usually takes these two bishops and last time we
saw this opening uh carissa expanded a little bit
more on the queen side and then there was a bishop
takes g3 um attacked so i think we might still see
an h5 by teddy if if carissa doesn't um you know
push the tempo in the center right she play king
g2 i think in this or is this a live position um i
believe okay position for some reason i thought i
saw kinky too maybe that was weird i literally saw
her pg like that was so weird bishop f4 that's why
we have canty in the commentary booth he's living
in the future and he's here i've seen these games
i already saw king g2 bro i guess you can see it
i didn't measure before queen d8 oh
i could play e5 but is that correct
um a little bit risky i i would probably bring
the queen back instinctively but you thought
definitely consideration there uh 97 yeah queen d8
we're back now it's more like a philadelphia but
like a semi-sloth but like they're five different
positions here it's definitely cramped though
definitely crammed christian i'm a fan of
with these cramped positions usually we like
to chop off the bishop with knight h5 or g5 very
aggressive yeah you need some space beautiful way
beautiful way to make some space here from teddy
yeah so i mean the bishop is going to be saved
bishop g2 and i think all carissa needs to do is
go rook d1 and something like e4 and i'm pretty
confident that she'll have a better position here
if you look at teddy's king going to the queen
side makes no sense with those pawns storming
and going to the king side is so weak now that
you've played g5 so not liking teddy's position he
gave up the two bishops he's got a very very weak
light square especially on f5 and i think that
you know e4 at the right moment by carissa is
is just going to blow the position wide open for
the bishop yeah you are correct we actually can't
even open a position and you man i mean like guys
when you have bishops on the board like this like
the worst thing you want to do you have to play to
the minor pieces you have and having two bishops
absolutely i'm trying to open a game so if e4
does happen we will have to probably respond
with the move d4 which kind of sucks because
it's very weak and we actually have to keep the
game closed as long as possible because we have
knights and those knights as soon as you open a
game it's a wrap e4 happens the bishop gets to
c3 that diagonal is monstrous it's uh it's over
actually if that does happen here yeah and e4 d4
what that means is eventually you know white's
going to save the knight but then comes f4 and
any e5 and those knights are going to get lead
around the board yeah this is scary you see he's
going down on time here because this is critical
this is very critical here this could be very
decisive now he is up a game so not that he can
afford to lose a game and he can but at the same
time here he wants to you know try to close this
i'll get that two-game lead that they're looking
for from in both parties knight c4 and ricky one
is very nice so i like rook a to d1 because i'm
expecting e4 opens up the e file and i expect
that looks to be necessary i feel like carissa
left the rook on a1 to deal with like a5 but it's
counterintuitive you almost don't want to rook
there so black can't execute a trade at some point
that's correct yeah i like to have to work on f1
and then playing f4 and also just like keeping the
rook ready to rook lift on that file and look at
that a5 does happen like immediately actually too
yeah i think i think uh rook a to d1 was maybe a
little bit more precise but still a big advantage
here for carissa i think that um this taking on
b4 business is almost like it just doesn't matter
i i would just go e4 and just for anyway you're
just doing it i just don't care about life i'm
just going to play it anyway e4 he says because
i i think the the advantage that carissa had
has disappeared uh yeah disappeared completely
yeah and actually the bishop's gone and he has
no worries anymore even uh even playing moves
like in this position bishop's gross on e7 so
we're probably going to see rookie a bishop f8
and bishop to g7 also um when this happens in many
cases you're able to uh even though the bishop's
on g7 even though the light squares are extremely
weak for black you're okay because the bishop's
covering the dark squares around the king so
it won't be it's going to be harder to create an
attack for white actually after this maneuver here
exactly yeah this this is a still good position
for carissa i think she should take it slow
um give up the idea of e4 because she doesn't
have two bishops anymore maybe more like e3
knight e2 knight d4 try to use that f5 square
great plan e3 92 94 i mean that's like that's
automatic you also have b5 but i don't have to
take i'm only getting the file but i mean c6 would
be weak but yeah oh yeah c5 is any two yeah so you
have to play e3 92 knight d4 that's an excellent
plan put that knight planted on e on d4 try to
get into f5 and work something work the position
because you could try to combine both of our plans
like put the knight on d4 and then suddenly the b5
move might make a lot more sense once you have
a little more pressure on the c file right very
good very good here from both parties here i mean
actually chrissie i could have played this better
there is e3 we're going to see bishop f8 most
likely and then 92 94. and there we go so how
about for black so we know that white wants to
play knight d4 maybe slide the queen to c2 get
out of knight d4 and prepare maybe b5 so how
about from black's perspective we've seen 94
come in bishop g7 probably and do you take that
knight on d4 do you think is it that powerful
um that's a great question i would probably wait
i would probably wait uh for a move or two just
to see if there's anything else to do and then
i'm like okay we gotta snap that uh you know at
the right moment here queen f6 nice hitting
f2 that's why again look you know that rook
if we would have did it with the other rook
we wouldn't have to worry about f2 right now
so this is kind of a funny position because f3
traps the knight but even though it traps the
knight i this is so i'm not i'm not sure that i
even like it knight takes g3 knight g3 rook e3
and i got those dark squares yeah they're kind
of making me a little concerned i think teddy's
got great compensation despite losing a piece
the eval bar actually thinks is the same i mean
they're like yeah you're down a piece but you know
white's only up a pawn right now yeah even though
you've got a piece for that so now we just if the
bishop gets active bishop d8 bishop v7 bishop da
bishop c7 that's way too long it feels like but
if we are able to activate that bishop on the
dark square diagonal where he's extremely
weak another opposite color bishop in game
this is going to be this could be very decisive
it's it's a game to say the least queen f4 looks
possible yeah queen of rolex possible and let's
point out it's not insane here to trade queens
that's how good black's position is like the pawn
structure for white is is completely shattered
the bishop on g2 is is no good um queen g6 though
keeping the queen's on the board preparing maybe
bishop to g7 maybe doubling rooks we'll have
to see what uh what his plan is maybe even f5
f5 yeah i actually i'm a fan of this dynamicism
here i like the p sacrifice i mean it was
involuntarily like a b sacrifice so he didn't
work exactly he didn't want to sack the beast
he actually you could see in his face like i can't
believe i dropped this piece right but at the same
time it's some good counter play he's going to
play on as we should it's a great game still
more than good counter play i as
soon as i saw the sack i thought
you know if it's a blitz game i'm
taking black ten times out of ten
ten times out of ten yeah every time yeah of
course playing england gambit stacking the queen
playing it against gm yeah beating them
online you know this is a privilege
yeah yeah it's a it's uh equal here two zeros
that's crazy zeros so what is uh what do we do
well that should just give you know maybe some
of the chat a perspective on to the position
it's it's two pawns for the piece but the the
compensation is so real that the evaluation is
basically equal and usually if the evaluation is
even but one side is down a piece you want to be
the side who's down a piece because it usually
means there's you know enough tricky elements
in the position and we see here this knight on
g3 just can't get involved uh the dark squares
like bishop d4 um gonna gonna get that check
in that second rank you know what the character
wanna faruga game was very similar to this where
he he could have sacked on g2 fabiano could have
sacked on g2 and had um when i did the post game
analysis for it was like a similar position where
like every move was just very bad even though
he had the extra pieces i think it was two
two-piece sacks something like that but he
was just a very bad position and this is very
similar work on a seventh rank dark square is
weak white has three out of five pieces on the
back right here and black is just coming all into
the position here rook a3 and uh yeah this is okay
two are okay three i think at some point even
eight five h4 h4 yeah f5 f4 i mean yeah you got
so many possibilities here look at all the
white's pieces on the back rank here but it's
a time scramble anything's gonna happen anything
that's gonna happen here so my opinion is that
in a time scramble it technically should benefit
black uh normally i would say that but um i think
i think carissa is is just generally happy to get
a time scramble because the position is so rough
that it's like you may as well take this to a coin
flip scenario yes correct 13 seconds 12 seconds
for teddy here so he shakes his head there's
a check you have to go king oh you got bistro
king h7 is kind of annoying we do have the
rick a3 move that helped right because bishop
d3 is no longer a threat so she plays rook
b3 it loses on the spot oh he missed rook
a1 i think rook a1 was the move yikes rookie
when was the move here now he's just down a
piece you can you got you got to be careful with
how many trades we do d3 oh man that's right
i don't know if chris is gonna go for an eight h5
but that's definitely playable and yeah she does
she sees it monster here trying to even out the
score bishop d4 check oh yikes this is annoying
yeah you gotta trade now and this is what i was
saying though don't be afraid to trade because
yeah i think it's still reasonable for black all
these extra pawns just like the what game was that
geary and um yeah exactly versus a million pounds
and steel gotta draw monster bishop check takes
knight d3 he's out he's activating the king the
king activation is great brook g3 is nasty oh
man oh yeah it was checking we got to move take 65
two seconds one second three f6 pre-moved removed
oh my goodness are they gonna take
a draw here neither of them wants to
lose no carissa wants more he wants more
look at teddy's facial expressions bro
oh my god oh my goodness get the man off the board
oh my goodness no he didn't yes he did wow teddy
teddy just like he just looked up to the man
upstairs there he reeled back in his chair a sigh
of relief i wish we had a heart rate monitor on
that game hey man you know i'm not even playing
him i just got like my skin got all hot just now
you know i'm like man i'm not even playing i'm
like whoa that hit me i i felt that i felt every
part of that wow and that was carissa's decision
you know and credit to her that's just the type of
i think that's more of a young player thing it's
that fighting chess you just never want to draw
that's just that feeling uh and she wanted more
there was a repetition the players were going
back and forth same moves and chess if you do
that three times that is a draw by repetition
she didn't want any part of that she said look
i'm gonna keep playing this i'm up a piece
i know i'm gonna down like a bunch of puns but
i'm gonna keep trying and unfortunately she tried
to her own demise and even teddy that's her loss
there man comes away with the checkmate with the
checkmate victory man i mean wow self-made there
that was like while in the time scramble you never
know what's going to happen there and i think it
is i guess something just with the younger players
here actually uh grandmaster hess actually said
the same thing about farouja in the game where he
was uh drawn or it was supposed to be just a draw
i think he was playing uh niels or something like
that and he should have taken the draw and uh he
was just trying to fight like is he playing for
a win like you're down a freaking you're down a
poland like how are you playing for a win here
right and it's and it was like no play for
a win but still wanted to play for a win
and that's a very nice fighting spirit to have
never giving up but also it can backfire a lot
i mean i've had you know have you ever had that
over the board where you you played on and then
when you've played an entire game and you feel
like you've been winning for most of it or you've
been up material for most of it it's hard to be
objective chess is an objective game but it's so
hard to remove yourself from the game and just
look at it and be like wait what's the position
like now doesn't matter what happened in the past
what's the evaluation now and you probably know
it's a draw but your brain is saying hey man we
got to make up for the for earlier when we mess
this up you know get that win but that's not the
right mindset that is correct here and actually i
think uh teddy now has that two-point lead guys
that two-point lead is something serious when
that two-point league gets in there psychology
starts to kick in as a player being down two games
now you're down two games back let's let's
not forget he brought the king's indian
he brought it back he's like all right i'm
up two games let's try to figure this out
maybe i can you know i can play my my favorite
like you said as we as all chess players we like
we got our stuff we love to play i'm sure he
loves to play d4 and playing against the kings
indian has probably thousands of games against it
and he's gonna play it again now i'm up two games
i'm going to play it a little bit differently now
and i like the approach that he's taken this time
it looks much better i don't see a clear attack
i mean b5 looks very very tempting from black
hair but and then he's actually thinking of
something here and he's his mind's blown as he
yeah i don't know like i don't know
what he's thinking of right now right
he was like boom oh man like he's
thinking of something right now
i uh probably he's he's wondering why he's
about to play bishop takes c5 like that's a very
committal decision but he he was looking like he's
never seen this position in his life what is this
right that's what he said yeah um pono d6 i
actually like white's position this is not the
dynamic counter play i would have in king's indian
defense all of my pieces are on the second seventh
and eighth ranks it's uh it's not a fun position
at all and king's indian is always supposed to
be fun this does not feel fun by far knight d5
and we live yeah yeah evan i mean this is ugly
knight f6 and queen h6 is a idea too if i
could if i could stop yeah okay never mind
never mind yeah she stopped but that
that was the the idea if maybe like rook
b8 or something i think that's definitely
consideration for just straight up knight
yeah taking queen h6 knight g5 rg1 f4 crushing
crashing c5 is hanging right now c5 and then
um maybe just back up but d6 is hanging but then
knight c7 does that work exactly i think i think
that works um rook c5 if knight d6 as james was
saying the line i think just goes knight c7 and
followed by queen d6 or knight takes a8 yeah and
actually bishop takes h3 as an inner between move
then there it might be defending uh the knight
depending on how it looks kind of weird not a lot
counter play stuff that you need and love in the
king's indian fence this stuff you'd look for but
again white's just you know a better position
here white honestly should win this game
but of course there's a lot of chess left you
know and we don't really know what what's going
to happen especially in time scrambles absolutely
and if that pawn on e5 almost disappears from
the board or somehow removes itself that bishop
comes alive everything changes in this opening so
white has to be very cautious not to let that
bishop out because we've seen teddy's king has
been stranded in the middle of nowhere with that
bishop active so he's had that experience before
but this is his best king's indian game we've seen
so far he really really adjusted well yeah he has
to probably keep this pace up if he's going to
play he needs to play in this manner here he made
the adjustments the necessary adjustments that he
needed to make here and it seems like it's working
for him in this game here now we still have about
five six minutes left in this one so we will see
the time uh on the game clock has expired so
this is a the last game of the five plus one
time control so what that means is that carissa
can bring that momentum right back with a win here
bring it within one game whereas teddy can almost
go into the break with the most commanding lead
of the match a plus three score so this is really
pivotal for the whole match right now yes pretty
pivotal is is correct i mean this is um two games
down you know last game here and we're going into
the faster time controls as well and then faster
time controls usually it's much harder to play
these same positions and you need to win let's
say she loses this game you know you would have
to win three more games now the bullet portion
is there not sure who the favorite is yet in
the bullet um we have to see who that is there
maybe teddy we have to see the ratings and see
things like that but three games like when you get
down more than two games it's very very tough to
come back even two games is is very hard here
this is almost a must win situation for chris
yeah rook a6 i like this move she basically
wants to take this pawn but she'd rather take
it with the rook so she's saying look let me
play rook takes d6 i like to pin that knight
rather than take with the knight and then suddenly
there's multiple pieces started hanging on the d
file i like that a lot very nice counter play she
found there rick a6 now the question is what does
white do how do you answer this move and teddy's
trying to figure whoa there's an idea wow there is
an idea okay now what if we take the bishop so
is the idea to check and just take that bishop
followed by bishop takes b5 and d7 yeah plant and
just plant yeah and just plant yeah this knight
on h3 is so gross like you can't do anything with
the other rook that you would love to um but it's
coming it's coming now especially after you take
on c8 so you might be you might be okay now but we
are far away from doing anything uh um active with
this knight on h3 so it really is down a piece
still when black has this is a terrible no no
d7 was not right i think he just confused uh the
two moves because bishop b5 first and then rook
six you throw in a4 right then you get the ball
you get d7 anyway so you got everything you wanted
in the dream story there now black is just up in
exchange with a weak pawn on d7 and the knight
out of the game looking crazy on the other side of
civilization so wow that this might actually turn
around uh quicker than we thought here because
i think teddy just maybe mixed up the moves in his
head i'm not sure if this is according to plan now
still great to have that pawn on d7 when you have
a pawn so far up the board look at the amount of
firepower that's required just to hold it there
um yeah yeah you're right firepower just to hold
it there yeah we have everything we have it's one
to spawn right here now is i guess he didn't want
to f7 is hanging right now so why are we taking
that i guess rook f8 i would probably just take
this extra pawn rook d6 looks um quite annoying
to me because that looks like it's dropping yikes
yeah what do you do you probably have yeah yeah
you guys look at this night you keep talking
about the night the poor guy is he's not even a
spec he's not even close enough to take photos
yeah no photos for you bro yeah no i mean this
guy's got a telescope to look at the action over
here this is gross that's a gross night guys don't
try that at home and what do they say at home guys
right nights on the rim are dim or whatever else
you want to call it the rhymes with them but
nights on the rim you don't put them there i mean
you if you do usually you would have to within two
moves or so move it back to the center so you
have some action because now coming back to it
this is it's detrimental it's it's decisive here
at this point he looks like he's going to take the
two rooks if ruth takes d7 absolutely i think
making the two wrists there take that queen d6
rook takes d7 um the idea that he's preparing
though tricky uh is bishop takes d1 bishop b3
and queen g8 mate if you try to grab uh grab the
pawn with the rook i still think that's the right
way to play but i think that's what he's up to
that's what he's up to absolutely i like that yeah
definitely he's staying in the game here so now
well rick d5 i want to play ricky i will try to
get rick d5 to work in some cases because you want
to try to open up some lines for that light square
bishop trying to get the bishop to these d3 and so
okay oh she goes for it she goes for it all right
we i mean there's no other way to do this i have
to take the queen for two rounds all right and she
says look you just don't have the coordination
if that knight imagine that it could just jump
into d5 or maybe white would be better who knows
yeah this would be this that yeah you're right i
would definitely prefer white in that position
with that knight on d5 but with it being like
what is your route how many move one two three ali
reza just did this in that draw game i mean yeah
probably like eight times eight times bro and
it was found to draw here but man this night
like you kind of have to do what you have to do
here but the question is how does black actually
crush like it's not that clear but you do feel
like black's better so i think knight d3 and
then bishop d1 to b3 is the route and then
and then your rook kind of guards your knight
e6 that's very nice that's very crafty bishop d1
bishop d bishop b3 and i can tuck my king on a2
and and i'm chilling and we we
we're trying to win this one okay
i want to start with bishop d1 like basically he's
talking about lock it up i want to lock your queen
down to that b pawn yeah that's bishop d1 oh
that was losing immediately what's the move well
i think it's i don't know if it's like you lose
a piece immediately but basically the queen to
f2 and just start to take all these pawns looks
like it yikes very passive knight i mean yeah very
passive all right we're supposed to work f3 right
just let it happen though he's missing that palm
hanging on b3 i think he just noticed he missed
it too yeah he's like what did i do like what
are you doing with me bishop takes b3 there we
go back in the game rook c2 and what do you do
oh my goodness whoa c is tilting she dropped the
queen no that was me wow oh my goodness that's
not a move on any and every level guys on any
and every level wow just drop the whole queen
and everything in between the ice gene that's
another one that's such a heartbreaker mm-hmm
such a heartbreaker because carissa had had hurts
made the comeback in that game so beautifully
honestly so beautifully to come back from that
tough opening and and then suddenly this could
have been just a one game difference in the break
but instead the the gap has widened it is now
three-point lead for teddy coleman as the end of
the five plus one portion uh james i mean thoughts
on the match so far i am excited i mean i'm uh i
got goosebumps and like sweating in here like i'm
playing so you know this is the type of chess that
i love to see every single day and this is why we
bring it to you guys because we know you would
enjoy it as well here at the i am not a gm speed
chess championship excited absolutely absolutely
and i mean at the expense of one of these players
you know our enjoyment is always at the expense
of someone unfortunately and in that game carissa
unfortunately laundry for a whole queen just
simply overlooked what what move teddy played
obviously she was seized that ten times out of
ten just didn't really notice what move he played
and she was so focused on you know converting
that into a victory but she's gonna have to focus
right back up and i think it's a great time
for a break for her for us because she needs
the time to sort of recuperate after that and
come back stronger in a three-minute portion so
james and myself will be back with the commentary
the three minute portion after this break
so
and while we are very excited to bring
you guys the three minute portion
of this match right here we have to remind
people that the full lineup of participants
has been announced for pogchamps three you
see some very big names there on the list um
the likes of michelle carr i see pokey name there
moist critical coming back again of course ludwig
and some very interesting names from outside
of the streaming world um although newcomer to
streaming logic is there he's been playing
a lot of chess and rain wilson so i think
people are very excited to see join so so
many names to mention but um the pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6 is coming up and james i think
that's going to be a very very exciting tournament
what do you what do you expect from pogchamps
three more of the same from the last editions
a little bit more the same and also some of the
betters xqc is getting nice i mean he's working
on his game so people actually taking it serious
then you bringing more people into it mr beast
youtube legend is playing you know you got logic a
uh a well-decorated rapper like this is sweet man
without all the all the diversity we're bringing
in the chess here and it's here at chess.com i
mean it's great bro it's i'm i'm excited for it
so it's gonna be a treat for you guys yeah so
don't forget about that box champs three coming
up um you know that's that's what's what you look
forward to next but right now we got the three
minute portion and i should say three plus one
so in all these formats in chess.com part of the
iron on gm tournament and the speed chest format
there's always that plus one second increment and
uh there's been a lot of flagging in this match so
far but i feel like that plus one second is hardly
noticeable it's not even a thing right that's one
second especially when there's so many things to
think about on the board you don't want to make
a mistake you are in time trouble did i make the
right move oh i hung my queen right that's just
how it happens you know and we've seen that here
so three one it's going to be much faster chess
a little bit more in inaccuracies here from both
sides and we're going to see maybe what if they
like switch up the openings i'm curious to see
what happens here you know i'm definitely into
like switching the game plan up when you get
to three minutes and one second anchorman or a
faster time there look at that charissa yeah
right right on playing b3 the larson system
so switching up the game plan from b4 just just
just b3 this time double finchetto and just play
even in a hippo type fashion well not after knight
f3 anymore we're just going to stick with larson's
system so i actually had a problem with this with
the black pieces i literally spent like two weeks
studying against this opening now i'm fine i
mean i put youtube videos out on it now like i
beat this person this is great now but man i was
getting crushed with this b3 system before how
about you yeah b3 uh just a great weapon for blitz
chess and now that we're down to the three minute
time control what you're gonna see is i think the
player's gonna be a little bit more loose in their
openings um they need to play a little bit faster
they need to be conscious of the the difference
and the time control and already we see the same
system from teddy it's like it doesn't matter what
charissa sets up he's he's going for bishop g4
he's taking this knight on f3 he's giving away
the uh the bishop pair he's going for the solid
stuff and he's incorporating h5 so it feels like
he's got a rinse and repeat strategy here you
know what actually you're correct and i mean
we've seen this like every game with black this is
the same thing nothing really different here but
he's going for the same setup h5 trying to sack on
g3 and now she's more accustomed to it because she
got sacked on before on g3 so she put the king on
g2 this time played h4 stopping the expansion of
the h5 pawn and honestly just consolidating now
we're probably going to play knight d2 and e4
is probably white's plan in these cases here and
black on the other hand i see castling queenside
and g5 maybe even g5 immediately wow that's very
aggressive yeah he has to make a decision because
there's the simple castle if you just want to you
know go back into the safe style g6 or there is
the full send mentality of your own castle oh
yeah e5 ideas oh yeah it's about to get nasty
here g5 knight g4 is rook g8s and we greats it's
very very good it's going to be very very nice
here i love black's attack here white is still
trying to figure out what to do we need to finish
our development and how does black actually black
has completed development white is still down like
two tempe in that sense there and even three if
you want to count the rook on a1 it's uh pretty
pretty rough c5 i do like this move you got to do
something c5 she going for b4 what do you think
about that i think it's not in time what about
your g5 like full send on the king's side g5 takes
and then you know get that knight into g4 or even
just knight h7 knight takes back and you know what
even almost you know of course it might not have
worked but i was even thinking after g5 plea h4
and then after sacrifice i mean that's too
wild that's that might be a little bit too much
but we're getting in there we are going to get in
there one way or another same ideas same ideas so
i'm wondering if takes in d5 is the option because
i mean that rook is hanging over there and d5 is
threatening d6 d5 e5 yeah i mean that that has to
be a possibility first off we eliminate one of the
attackers which is the knight and then we play d5
and about to take another attacker and play rook
h1 yeah i do not like this anymore black's in
a lot of trouble he probably should have played
like knight h7 yeah just take him push i would go
i would go e takes d5 and i think i'd be fairly
happy in a blitz game that at least my center is
fully intact g5 is hanging you know i got knight
e5 coming in um and wow f5 five played oh yes i
take it i don't have to understand but what if i
don't though what's his next move h4 scary maybe
rick h1 he still has some real some real threats
yeah there's definitely a case for like queen b3
strangely enough that pawn is not that easy to
defend on e6 actually you're right and knight f8
is not a nice looking move wow you would think b5
would be i mean good like india didn't like
it but it's not like it's terrible terrible
no no it's easy no it's definitely definitely
not a bad move i mean uh chris has got to get
her attack going um so completely understandable
but i guess it's like when you see h4 you know
that there are big threats in one move when you
see p5 i don't see the big threats right it's like
it just opens some files you're right right takes
okay queen takes c6 being obvious so then we play
e3 you gotta stop that maybe you could play f3
if e3 okay i did not like that one really wow
now this this is more like um you know maintains
the uh maintains the position because maybe queen
c6 is d5 go for a bunch of trades and trade the
queens off so he's looking he's saying look rook
there h4 and you know good luck you're either
made me or i made you right and actually white
is definitely not mating because especially the
beautiful move rick d's to ga now we just moved
a king over king d8 and we chilling in the center
of the board you know even when you think about
d5 i think it's high time like yeah you write d5
h4 is coming yeah i think we need this move it's
there it's on the board d5 is there and sacrifice
material nine takes d5 stacking on h8 or taking
the rook on h a so we got a pawn and a rook for
the two pieces and then we play rook b1 and maybe
rick be seven that's quick you gotta be quick
knight takes d5 and bishop takes he just delay
the attack get rid of those two rooks or at least
one of them and fight you know rook v1 rook d1 c6
there it is lots of attacks look at the attacking
chances carissa yip is swinging back just like
that very nice very good i like it that's a gig
deploying some great counter play here sacrificing
material so now um yeah black's definitely on
the defense here rook b1 scary to me rook b1
followed by rick b7 now the knight can be very
active on c5 but it's probably not enough to be
something decisive yet it's not even close to the
king and even if you take on c5 i have queen g6
in many cases question is what do you do about d5
right now though i have no idea i mean this queen
needs to be saved uh queen b5 queen a4 that's fine
i mean just hit that pawn that's that's all that
that looks like needs to be done queen takes c5
rooks oh it can't even go rook c1 oh there we
go that was uh between c5 was good yeah and now
we can go right see one yeah ooh look at these
pawns though carissa's down time oh it's a time
scramble oh man we got now rubbing your hands
together because you don't know what you're about
to see in this yeah time scramble time everyone's
strapped in hey put on your seatbelt guys put on
your seatbelt mine's over all right let's see what
happens queen takes f5 and we live just take the
point it's free yeah we have five singing a queen
outside hanging a four-pack is nice though there
it is she found it a second time gotta take on g3
rick h2 is real okay all right queen g3 oh gotta
play queen h3 yeah knight d5 to e3 is a huge move
ooh check rick have one check what are you
looking at okay is hanging as well e4 is hanging
i can run around king f2 king de1 f5 check check
oh my goodness look at this walk oh wow g4 whoa
that works i guess almost rook f4 we need to
put rook f4 there oh my goodness to lose this
something's wrong 65 yeah rick c5 queen takes e5
snap on g7 have a nice day c7 7 yep c7 knight c8
five nice moves nice moves working five is nice
yeah three seconds on the clock rook f8 work at f8
rook takes e5 oh oh there it is bam tactics
win games tactics win games whoa careful though
is a good move oh my goodness what a game king
f6 you can catch 83 93 93 oh my god wow please
help me oh my goodness oh man nasty stop it
another blunder stop it please in the christmas
i can't take it anymore oh my goodness and it's
just that's the one tactic you have to watch over
by the way even at the very end when when the when
the fork happened maybe king f3 king e2 take the
pawn on d2 instead of going up the board maybe
there's still a chance there of yeah knight in
a pawn but wow oh man i can't do i can't take it
anymore now that's four games here she's on four
games guys and here psychologically you can even
see it in her face here slightly that it's just
she understands geez like i'm you know i'm down
i'm down that was a tough game i was doing pretty
good and now i'm down four games with you know a
lot of time left here but we want to try to you
know stop the bleeding here we are down four games
and and that's story though that that really has
of the match like you talk about good positions
but not getting the results that's carissa's uh
you know matching in nutshell right now because
she's playing very well and she's putting herself
in a position to succeed finding that d5 move in
the last game so necessary to avoid getting mated
on the spot and teddy just seems to be mr nerves
of steel right now and time pressure he is cool
i mean there are blenders left and right so he is
blundering but he always seems to come out ahead
so he's making the second last blunder of every
game that's right it's all about who makes that
last blunder there and man it was uh definitely
carissa yet ouch it was crazy game this is what
we came to see though today so i'm curious hey
i'm taking on e5 what you think about that knight
takes c5 queen eight well no it doesn't work i was
thinking if knight takes queen h5 and then maybe
rook the ones and like you know just going for it
right you know okay long castle right that's just
my style there but h4 i'm not feeling i think just
g4 and i'm good yeah i think teddy is looking at
the the position and saying look f4 is a real
big issue i think he's gonna go like knight g1
try to play bishop c492 cover the f4 square and
he doesn't need to take crazy risks so far what's
happened is he's played pretty solid and when
there is a sacrifice that does work he usually
takes it but otherwise he sort of sits back you
know almost waits to be attacked he's like you
know porcupine you don't bother me i don't bother
you and uh yeah yeah that's right that's right
he's prickly you know and then you see
these pawns they're very over extended here
only covered by of course the pieces but these
over extended pawns in in-game will be pretty
tough but also right now in the middle game
we're going to attack them just like bishop d3
knight c5 being a move attacking and defending at
right right now he shook his head immediately
yeah he shook his head immediately guys he's
not feeling that and knight bishop d3 was just
a blunder in a way knight do three check and
you know we have a a great position to be honest
now we do we're getting rid of the light square
bishop which is the asset of the disposition
yeah black's fine now this is a great country
great game here so i like knight e7 um
because obviously knight f6 drops the
e pawn but also in 87 has the idea to maybe go
to g6 and play f4 in the future or just knight c6
to watch over that pawn again so loving uh loving
the way that carissa is dealing with this opening
um trading queens makes perfect sense even keeping
the queens on queen c4 if it's more your style
totally reasonable as well actually yeah i would
like queen c4 i do like that move a lot because
i'm not trying to keep the queens on because it's
more you just have more attacking chances and if
i want to attack you ever i want to keep pieces
more on the board especially queens queen c4 was
pretty nice actually like that but of course this
trade does favor black steel we got the bishops
open position we got to be here she didn't want
to deal with the move knight a5 which is why she
played the move b6 right then a5 is one of those
funny looking moves that hits the bishop hits your
pawn and leaves you kind of uh blindsided so uh
deals with that and 97 looks like the next plan
teddy's knights just have nowhere to go yeah
night night okay it's not having a good night
not tonight okay that's crazy man there's
more where that came from oh man right right
oh man but uh castling uh rick oh you can't
play rook d7 anyway i was thinking so yeah
what about king placement what are you putting
the king maybe king f7 uh i'm thinking king
f7 although the move f3 is making me consider
castling a lot more than king f7 just because
that file might get open but okay now that i
see this i think king f7 is still fairly solid
yeah king of summer yeah king h2 yeah definitely
loving black's position we got the open file and
both bishops here um what white should be looking
to do is trying to trade one of the knights for
the bishops but it's virtually impossible right
now because we don't have squares to even go to
knight d3 we have to get our knight off the back
rank because it's pretty pretty tough honestly
yeah yeah and then and then you know like knight
g6 follows or king f7 king e6 but knight d5 very
aggressive saying look i mean uh e3 pawn is weak
and we see this move now my question is after
knight d3 how do you how do you meet that you have
to go rook a to e and then what's another thing
after that like e4 and if you take maybe take
with the rook and then try to take that pawn on e5
that's a great plan bro actually pushing takes i'm
gonna have to yeah shoot he going for it too yikes
yeah black this is kind of what black didn't
want i mean because white's white's fighting
back now this is a good fight what about f4
that's a weird looking i think it might be
the best move because i'm looking at f takes e
and rook takes e and i'm saying that's good for
white so f4 i like your move this looks necessary
that's right so now we keep it a little close but
that's what white wants in a way but we still
we can't close position that we can't use the
knights in i mean that's the worst position
to be in like yeah i have a closed position
i got the knights but i can't use them the way i
want to you know bishop b7 and we can go to d5 oh
rick d7 is a thing yeah nice counter eddie he's
working his position and that's why bishop b5
to keep an eye on that i think generally speaking
here i mean you're not upset trading that night
that bishop always watches the h4 pawn the
knight on b3 let's face it is so bad here
rook g8 we're gonna see a5 from carissa
so far this has been honestly a master
class with the two bishops so let's see if
she can convert this game uh she needs it
she needs it in this in this match format because
the three-minute portion you know only has 30
minutes left in it so she's got to start getting
some wins in yeah she has to stop the bleeding
here we haven't seen a win from her in many games
here actually four games so knight's coming to d5
you better be right oh yeah there we go 92 93 95
very nice here very nice play from teddy now it's
a time scramble so we don't know what's going
to happen here anything can happen right here
hold on guys anything can happen like this yeah
oh first okay yeah bishop before definitely yeah
can you have one good before there it is great
move there rook to d3 and probably just snap
it off i think snap it off probably
just snap it off i think we take that
uh flags oh i see what's happened she dropped
out of the the zoom call on screen and
and she just disconnected she's straight
disconnected she's not in the zoom call
the camera is gone oh my goodness
there's there actually couldn't be
worse timing on that we were just like there's
a queen hang in some end game positions
there's you know forgetting about the time there's
a disconnect it's like what literally what else
can go wrong as a competitor that this is such
unfortunate such an unfortunate series of events
because we were just praising this whole game and
to disconnect right right when you need to play
that bishop c3 move this is heartbreaking it is
heartbreaking it is heartbreaking i mean probably
knocking things off the table i'm sure at the
chess bra family i've broken many chairs and mice
that we use so you know i understand that's pretty
it's a tough situation but knowing the type of
competitor that teddy is i mean he's gonna be the
first to to probably not want to take this point
um on the scoreboard um knowing like what kind of
sportsman teddy is so yeah we'll have to see how
this gets uh resolved by chess.com and hopefully
we first of all just get carissa back in the call
and get things set up again as i think she's still
um she's still not there but yeah knowing him i
think he'll be the first to say look i don't want
to win a game like that you know even even though
it's a competitive match yeah that's how even
jordan said that today you know when he won
yeah that's not the you know greatest way to win
of course the clock is a piece though and that's
the rules so and that's a preferred win but it's
still a win there it's pretty tough it is it's on
the board so it is seven to two um pending just
getting uh carissa back on the call that's the
most important thing so we can uh continue this
match here teddy is just uh standing by and uh
james i mean we're we're just seeing a kind of
an unfortunate collapse by carissa it seems like
every game she has not just chances to win but
she might even be winning um all these games
and uh quite unfortunate that that so many things
have just knocked on her way this match yeah it's
pretty tough to say you know pretty tough to
see but you know we have a lot more where that
came from today it's exciting chess and hopefully
she can bounce back from what's happened so far
right and uh i think what we're going to try to
do is sort out the tech issues and make sure we
can just get carissa back on the call so we can
continue this match um and so we're going to call
it uh the half time uh of the three minute
portion right now and i think we were due to
to to have our halftime break anyway so um
we'll be back the rest of the three minute
portion we'll get carissa back on the call
and get things sorted out so james canty iii
and myself are gonna be back with commentary
right after this guys don't go anywhere
and we are back thank you guys for sticking around
and uh you know james i think i think we've all
done this before but carissa just pulled
the classic yet unfortunate forgot to plug
in the laptop trick so i mean it really really
is too bad because unfortunately that's something
that that she was in control of and and you
know that's her responsibility and in a match
format like this that point is going to count
towards teddy's score as it absolutely should um
and we're just going to go straight into the next
game the match clock has been set to reflect that
and we are in the next game it's seven to two
now for teddy coleman in this match yeah seven
to two he's uh commanding leads so far with the
bullet portion coming up here so we're gonna have
to have carissa definitely come out out of the
bag here and find something much stronger than
what's been happening today yeah it's just it's
just been the case of you know like a series of
unfortunate events uh that's just the only way
to put it because carissa has every opportunity
to get back in this match you know as soon as
one of these games goes her way they could all
start rolling her in her direction because teddy
has played a fantastic match but carissa has has
had chances to win in probably almost every single
game every game yeah every game it was something
different there they getting in time troubled
and in time scrambles and the time scrambles uh
usually actually they've been favoring teddy as
we've seen here so we see like he just holds a
little bit better under pressure there and uh it's
pretty tough to see here so she's gonna have to
speed up a little bit i think but not and it can
be inaccurate while doing so so we're down the
same line also with the queen a3 i forgot where
the queen was last time it must it was like on d1
or something maybe well we saw the uh we saw the
line queen a4 um with the knight on b5 and then um
you know the queen going to b4 to hit that d-pawn
queen b8 was was forced as a response and then a5
to kick the queen back so totally different style
here because as you mentioned the queen was on d1
before and white was just expanding with the pawns
this looks like you know both queens all all uh
you know shoved way over on the queen side there
teddy is saying look forget that queen side stuff
um you know let's defend this uh this d-pawn and
maybe go back to this bishop g5 plan actually yeah
that is um that is some especially called theory
that is correct bishop g5 and also weirdly enough
bishop h4 sometimes it's a very really weird move
but bishop h4 in some some lines you were able to
do this but the bishop g5 is excellent trading off
the dark square bishop and coming in with knight
f4 and again even having f4 as a move we're moving
the knight and moving it into h4 and playing g5 g4
in many cases here i do like black's position
white's queen is out of play over there especially
after this b6 move great move from teddy
stopping the c5 potential from ever happening
exactly um definitely i mean i would give a lot
of consideration to moves around the king like
just bishop f1 maybe tucking it away bishop f2 as
well um b4 takes takes hits the the pawn on b6 and
that that could start to mobilize things a little
bit on the queen side uh but carissa is faced with
you know pretty obvious idea that that teddy wants
to play this bishop g5 idea at some point you know
he's going to try to trade off the star square
bishops and all these dark square pawns are giving
him really good dark square control something
to be careful of if you lose this bishop on
e3 and you know what i think after bishop g5
if there's bishop f2 then you play bishop h4
if they go back to e3 then you play f4 and you're
able to play bishop g3 and queen h4 in many cases
i remember seeing some attacking stuff like that
and it's it's pretty scary how that attack looks
it could definitely be a possibility here let's
see what happens good idea to keep in mind f4
bishop h4 bishop g3 with the queen coming out
and you're saying you know um don't care what's
happening on the queen side it's all about the
king and it's about checkmate ending the game
absolutely check made into the game right but
of course we do have to worry about that d6
pawn like as you mentioned so he plays knight
h4 i like it with the idea f4 g5 and we live
king h8 rook g8 going crazy yeah that's going
to be scary now f4 always gives up the e4 square
to the knight so in chess there's always a give
and take it's not like black you know just gets
a free attack from nothing so of course that is
going to come with its own concessions and it's
just whether whether or not black is in time and
that comes down to calculation i think we did see
f4 last time something like that i don't know
if f4 happened is f4 even a possibility there
uh from white you mean or yeah from white actually
yeah from just stopping f4 it's a concession in a
way but right it also opens up some lines maybe we
try to get the knight order bishop to d4 actually
and then stopping f4 from black almost for good
yeah that seems pretty reasonable actually um
interesting yeah so now i'm looking at c5 and
i'm i'm almost playing that immediately here he's
not even thinking about it yeah not even thinking
about that move bro c5 i'm not even thinking about
it yeah that looks super strong right now brooke
g6 uh i'm looking at bishop f1 and i feel like i'm
holding everything together yeah he's pretty good
as black here probably f4 rick h6 like you got
to go for this now teddy i don't know what he's
thinking he played rook g6 yeah i didn't like it
f4 at least hit something and then rook h6 trying
to give me sack like you feel like you're here
because it they're going to she's going to fix it
figure this out on the queen side if you're not
you know accurate here yeah c5 is real
crushing move rook into b7 or rook to b6
hitting the d6 pawn both look strong
and you have to ask yourself like
where is the the crushing blow on the king side
like bishop f4 and queen g5 maybe just all in
i like that i do like that i like and actually
bishop f4 rook h6 knight takes f3 and many cases
there i like e4 queen e5 yeah and trying to sack
on f3 when you get that rook on h6 f3 sack is
potential it just has to be right you got
to line it up queen e5 bishop f4 like you
mentioned which is really nice so i see a
nasty attack for teddy but he is in time yeah
and look at teddy i mean he he has these games
where you feel like he's so solid and then he
has these games like this where his position is
going to fall apart if he doesn't find checkmate
right right yeah here is this i guess a miss
move order here because he definitely had a
huge advantage of course the engine loves why here
but this is not an equal position but you will say
that black is definitely fighting for mate here
yeah but now it's back down to equal here i love
it that's that's just the nature of a tumultuous
attacking position like we have on the board and
all of a sudden in just two moves it's just you
can't do that you can't get away with that like
there's no possible way you're going to be able
to take this bishop on d7 and get away with it
i'm thinking what bishop at bishop c1 the queen
is the nasty one it just forks the rooks oh my
goodness queen g4 yeah it's a really funny
looking yeah look at the simple move here
guys i mean when does that ever happen look
at the geometry there yeah i understand what
he's doing why did you do that though what are
you doing with your life here oh my goodness
oh my goodness that was gross that was so bad
wow yeah kenti has no what the bishop's hanging
i am oh man look hey let's get this off the
screen stream's over y'all sorry sorry we're
gonna have to come back tomorrow what oh my
goodness what was that oh my goodness wow wow
yeah let's just go to the next game go next thing
we're going to talk about that we don't even talk
about that that's a bad word okay wow okay so
that game i mean you saw the evaluation bar
knight takes g2 was the only move you couldn't
do actually you couldn't do that one first you
had to do anything else right queen g4 like you
said was forking the rooks that was gg and it
was just crazy it looked like pogchamps
out there you know it was uh in the end
carissa you could say she got that win
whatever way she got it messy you know uh in in
incorrect moves left right and center who knows
who cares if you're in the carissa camp you're
saying look i'm back on the on the board here
i made up that that disconnection let's go yeah
you know and that might be exactly the energy
that she needs to get right back in this match
oh yeah you know i understand if i win if i
beat hikaru right king and pawn right i got
a king of pawn he got every one of his pieces and
he flags guess what i'm framing it i'm framing it
you know i'm letting everybody know yeah i beat
him yep i did i did did did he win no he didn't
right so okay i won i won absolutely every single
time and that's exactly where she is here we'll
take it we will take it you know a dub is a dub
okay i know how it doesn't matter you know the
clock is a piece too so and we're gonna take what
on earth do we have in this game i'm just gonna
quickly play through these again because uh we
actually see carissa going e6 97 and completely uh
unorthodox she is just uh you know bombarding the
center with c5 with e6 d5 and i i like it already
that's right i love it i love it for black
here open lines for the bishops now i think
i would uh i think and even evaluation state
says is equal to preferably black here i do
like black's position slightly better but i think
white's doing quite fine they do have like h5 is
always going to be annoying and uh maybe trading
but if you trade tonight that bishop becomes nasty
on g7 so you got to be careful yeah black's
definitely a fake h6 here i if white plays h6
you're just you're lost basically uh so you can't
let that happen h6 is neat yeah actually you were
right yeah yes that's over with oh he has bishop
h8 now and it also closes the file yes that's this
is another way to do it um i still think h6 is
probably good because you know there's just going
to be some attacking uh motifs to worry about here
but still castling by black nice way to solve that
problem as well yeah actually here i mean this is
uh not that it doesn't look that good for white
so what i'm doing is i'm just going all out
i mean actually i do that any every game no
matter how it looks i'm trying to go out all out
castle queen side miss of a6 and go from eight
sack segment bobby fischer but i'm saying d4 d4
d3 by black looks oh that's annoying that's real
annoying right there d4 i got to go 94 you play d3
i have to play bishop d1 that's gross do i have an
in-between move like can i play knight f6 i think
i think yes yeah i think link knight f6 is a great
move and then you open up the ac file as well yeah
yeah so i might have to temper myself d4 and 84
i probably need another move there i don't
know if it's f6 i don't know what it is
oh you can't move tonight yeah but f6 right that
seems pretty strong actually f6 kind of annoying
bishop h6 crazy line queen c7 rook c1 man king's
in the center yeah he's still not playing knight
f3 for obvious reasons we just don't want to open
that bishop so you're still trying to go d4 d4
you can't take that yikes i mean look at her piece
play beautiful got the queen out of the pin here
the knights look beautiful there covering 16
squares total actually yeah yeah so this is uh
beautiful nights the bishops are backing them
great play come on all right all right hey y'all
wait wait candy i gotta ask you and your hat is
that a move let me let me get closer to the camera
you see that right there you see the hat that's
it that's not a move knight d5 look i mean the
development's not there the king cannot castle
either direction both central files are open on
the king i mean this is this looks like just no
you just can't do this don't try this at home
don't try this at home okay do not take it
upon on d5 like that oh my goodness i mean so
just to let people know she gave up that rook on
purpose right so she wanted to go rook d8 so bad
she says look take me on d8 i'm gonna take
back knight d4 now looks great and just all
these pieces flow flow flow they come in with
tempo yeah this is flowing right flowing flowing
flowing i mean of course like you still have
to finish development guys we are still in uh
fayette students as phases of the game and
the phase one is development have we finished
our development here the kings on f1 the rook's
still on h1 now it's pretty active but it's not
doing anything and the knights on g1 so okay we're
trying to fight as much as we can and actually the
evaluation bar is in white's favor now she messed
this up huh yeah yeah i'm crazy the sacrifice i
think a computer is probably always going to look
at and say you know i'm not a big fan of that
we could have done that better but when when you
think about just the human perspective i think the
chances yeah yeah i think it's still really really
reasonable for carissa i i like where this is
trending that's true actually yeah of course that
you put that uh england gamut queen sack and an
engine and they hate it but you you you're beating
like me we've seen it done you beat gm's with
it so it does it's all about the you know how it
feels when you're sitting at the board or you're
sitting at the computer playing against it and if
you can find a way out then then it's might be not
so good but if it's difficult to play that's
exactly what a good sacrifice will do to you
yeah great sacrifice right you know many times
so yeah actually knight of three is now on the
board here he's he's trying to do can you play
knight g4 knight g4 looks interesting i'm also
saying look if i just take like knight takes on
f3 or or just take this pawn first i'm saying look
you can't mate me down the h file queen h7 check
is as far as you're going i go king f8 i'm safe
and the king on f1 is not that impressive so
again i i'm kind of liking what what karissa's
done here and and hang on there's definitely
oh wait a second yeah knight takes e2 hidden c1
knight the knights hanging knight d3 is that the
move that might be the only move i don't know i
mean you got we got a lot of pieces hanging here
okay rookie a lot of pieces hanging a lot of stuff
hanging here guys uh rook takes d2 rook d2 you
can't take on e5 whoa this is scary no mates i
don't see nothing dang that bishop is uh queen
takes b2 oh just take the queen yeah that's a
blender just take the queen brook d1 looks good
c6 looks bad that was very bad yeah c5 is coming
behind it now you gotta do something okay sorry
there's four seconds on the clock here yeah i
think reasonably speaking this is probably a draw
but um it'll come down to somebody's mistake in
time pressure i think yeah somebody's gonna flag
some or or drop something like we've seen before
that queen it happens man at time scrambles are
the hardest part of chess we say is when you get
this low on time and trying to stay accurate and
not blunder this is very very hard to do guys
extremely hard okay double hold up double on the
bubble rook takes rook b7 rook b7 big fella let's
go come on come on work b7 that works no way to
stop me that works too oh my goodness he's finding
the moves hit him oh man this is gross king c6 is
just that's that's uh that's a classy classic oh
he stepped out of the way for the checks i got
it yeah i got it that's a meaty one oh my bro
what rook va has checked me that
he was setting up the whole thing
almost now he's dropping a pawn on g2 i'm shedding
tears right now what i'm crying this is incredible
this is this is i don't even want to say nothing
it's a draw okay nobody lost all right whatever i
mean this is ridiculous here it happens wow time
scrambles okay you gotta remember guys it's time
scrambles so in time scrambles you're you don't
know what's gonna happen you may think he was up
a queen and then you're not that's how it happens
every single time every single time miss mayton
won one move game over yeah and guys this is not
a pre-recorded segment uh trailer for pogchamps iv
this is this is we're actually live right now
promising live this is probably that wow that
that is a big time miss because it looked like he
was setting that up for the checkmate like this i
mean the intricate king c6 like the way he wrote
that great it was excellent it was excellent check
move it over and i was like oh he got it he set it
up and then dropped it you know wow just like wow
man and it's been in every direction so right
now like the last couple games it has to be said
that it's looking a little shakier and shakier for
teddy like he has his his moments where you think
he's set it up and then he misses that at the
end that's reminiscent of what's been happening
to carissa this whole match yes yes actually
she uh dropped the queen there and didn't have
problems with the connection there and dropping
games here she's still down the four point so it
hasn't increased so that's good in a way
we have kind of stopped the bleeding she
um as she should look at it that way hey you
know what cool we're down four games but let's
not increase it anymore let's get this back and
really just focus and actually cargo has a great
statement about losses and things like that
you have to have a short-term memory loss and
in things like this like big events and playing
over the board chess you have to have a short-term
memory loss when it comes to losses like this
because you can take all this into the next games
and you're not seeing your missing mates you're
hanging queens and not playing like your real self
because you are still held on those losses yep no
that's a great piece of advice for you know pretty
much any competitor i would say but especially
valuable in chess and especially valuable in blitz
chess because there are so many there's a high
volume of games that you know being able to forget
those losses is exactly what you want to do memory
of a goldfish yeah maybe we have a goldfish yeah
teddy bishop c4 just played and i'm kind of
liking what chris is doing i like the f4 move
you can go g3 stabilize there you got great
control of d5 but i think we are you know more
or less in like a theoretical position here i
think um yeah i like this for well i think it's
dynamically equal but i really like white just
because of the control i think we have more
control here but those bishops are monsters
i mean that's some compensation for real
you open the game the wrong moment that's lights
out absolutely lights out with the pawns together
like even taking on e5 would be a huge blunder
like just having both the pawns and the bishops
being able to swipe the board right king h8
happening or ga so you kind of have to even
opt in for g3 there it is king h8 rook g8 and
we great i mean how many times have we said that
today putting this real quick well there's been
so many attacking games that you know we've been
able to use the catchphrase right look at that
man richie hayden be great it's awesome queen h4
and i don't even care about the d6 pawn
um being weak because you can't i remember
studying the stressing off theory and it was
even knight orbs too but you learned that
there's two things you can't do you can't do both
as white you can't attack the d6 pawn and control
the d5 square so you're either going to do one
or the other and if you're controlling d5 square
what i'm going to do is just play around it and
try to go for other things because you're not
doing anything from there but if you try to take
the d6 pawn then you're going to have to move the
knight from d5 which costs time so let's see
how she plays point or top teddy plays this
yeah now taking here that's to take the f5 pawn
and knight takes e5 play because look if you take
with the pawn it seemed like knight takes f5
was just in the position of free pawn for the
taking so knight takes e5 hits the bishop on c4
bishop b3 forced back um from carissa and now
knight takes f5 that is the threat what are you
gonna do about that i was just thinking that
what is the move like we have active pieces now
i really like white's position i mean it's active
it's activity activity what is uh gary kasparov
says uh activity will trump material most times so
activity looks really good here for white active
pieces rook f4 doubling right we got a lot of
stuff here and the d5 square is definitely helping
us we would love to have a queen on h4 as black
but i mean we can't do anything really as you
see teddy's going down on time trying to figure
this thing out queen yeah the rook is going to
slide over to e1 in general the king to h1 move
is is one that i'm always looking to get in the
position um and chris says look i want to solidify
the d5 square you talked about putting pressure
on d6 or controlling d5 i think it's pretty clear
which one she's doing right yeah it's pretty clear
we don't care about that d6 pawn we're just going
to stay on d5 and stay live king h1 out of the
way that's automatically cannot stay there like
you just can't yeah it's also threatening bishop
takes d5 winning material right now yeah a little
bit too long here to be honest king h1 is like
automatic here thinking a little bit too long even
though teddy's down on time you want to use this
to your advantage maybe what else could she be
calculating i honestly don't know seems scary that
seems like too much on that yeah rook d4 is the
only other move i can think of unless
unless she's missing bishop d5 as a threat
and thinks like you know i don't have to do
anything because that f4 is covered like and even
f4 is a threat honestly okay there is the king
age one there it is knight f4 oh there's some c2
c2 and wood and she's ready for that okay she was
ready she was calculating what to do after that
now knight takes f4 can you do that maybe
not if knight takes queen takes e3 knight g6
then we can perpetuate the very
least so knight takes queen takes
man we in there bro that's in there knight
takes f4 you mean and i takes f4 knight g6
yeah knight takes f4 queen takes c3 brook
takes f4 and then queen takes e3 though
that's quite a good cause because you're
right if you get that knight g6 and that's
you really are in there yeah so maybe 97 um but
you're still sacking the knight okay yeah 97 now
now 94 your first idea the the knight's not
hanging right and i think this is great nice
great job carissa swinging she's looking back here
she's swinging like i'm not going down like that
queen night five coming in like save the
queen queen h4 knight f5 hitting each six
queen h4 teddy's down to 20 seconds under 27. i
think he's gonna take on c3 yeah i was trying to
say anything yeah you got to take that and that's
just crushing but what's the move it's not that
clear no not that clear at all um i mean knight
f5 drops the bishop it's hidden right now like
she he's getting destroyed it went from plus 10 to
plus one like i think rook takes e6 rook takes h6
and it was lights out last turn oh that's nice
you're right you're right yeah that's it and
i think i think he might have noticed that but
she did my goodness sevens mate bishop g6 such
a good move wow can i take it dang oh my goodness
she gotta move yeah queen h1 snap snap okay these
knights are barely being held together wow held
on by a thread here all right guys hold on to
your seat belts here you know what happens in the
time scrambles you know what happened goodness
time scrambles i don't know what's about to happen
at all oh that that doesn't work it doesn't work
what is going on right now that is
not a move oh my goodness that's over
i have never seen a mouse slip like that
like that that is something else just breathe
that is something out that is a basically you're
you're so in that time scramble moment that you
just played with brook takes f2 and you haven't
even let go of the piece yet yeah when you're
trying to drag your mouse over to each other yeah
yeah i think she i think she considered rookie one
and that's why but she did work at three
so what was it was a slip it was just
i think the most was literally still grabbing
the rook and she was like just trying to move
over yeah to the h3 square yikes oh man
man just tough pre-moves here guys like
five games i mean just unfortunate events today as
you mentioned today like unfortunate events today
for carissa here yeah it almost speaks to somebody
who might not be like it speaks to a very strong
player who might not be used to the online format
but the strange thing is that's not carissa like
she plays online all the time she's so used to the
format she she plays bliss she does puzzle rush
like she's very competitive online so to see her
like have these mouse issues or spots of blindness
missing free queens stuff like that is very out
of character yeah i think it's uh there's many
quotes to this actually from boxing if people are
familiar with mike tyson they say you always have
a plan until you get hit in the face and that's
exactly what uh sometimes it becomes that and
psychology part even in in boxing like when you
get hit and you get stunned or it's just like oh
i'm shaking a little bit being down so many games
here is psychology part and even gary kasparov
talks about that part the psychology part of chess
is sometimes even bigger than the moves itself so
here it could be a lot of that it could be a lot
of psychology being down and these positions are
tough and then i'm getting in time trouble
and it's more thinking about everything else
than it is about the game yeah yeah no that's a
there's a lot of outside factors you know there's
a lot more than just chess going on in this match
right here and carissa i mean we look at the
game clock and there's you know four and a half
minutes left so it looks like this is favorite
to be the last game but um but you know we have
seen quicker games so it just really depends
how quickly uh these players are going to play
this one out but this could very well be the
last game in this three-minute portrait in this
three-minute portion yeah with uh teddy being up
five games here a commanding lead going into
the bullet section so who do you think's if
well uh i don't know who's a favorite in bullet
i'm going to put my prediction out there i don't
know i am rooting for carissa in the bullet
there to grab some games there because these
time scrambles it's honestly anybody's bet
there but you got to be a little bit we get
they have to be a little bit more accurate than
what we've seen so far in the bullet sections
yeah no i in the bullet i mean we have everything
to to look forward to and just as a commentator
i'm rooting for carissa to bring this match
close so that we can have an exciting finish
rather than have one player run away with it as is
probably going to be my answer every single time
yeah but uh but we'll have to see teddy is
for sure solid and he's been getting the
upper hand in most of these time scrambles you
know whether it's been clean or not he that's
where he's gotten a lot of his points this match
that's right actually his time scrambles and he's
came very close there having good positions even
winning when he was not supposed to at all which
actually psychology borrowed there i would keep
playing on no matter what now because i know that
like you know if i'm losing all the time and time
scrambles and you kind of know what to expect but
if i'm like hey it's up in the air down the queen
i'm still winning like okay yeah you may as well
may as well play them on it we gotta play them
on we've got a pretty unique position here in
this one the brooks have just disappeared from
the h file um carissa has a hard time castling
here to match teddy because the the bishop just
can't develop that easily like you want to play
bishop v6 hit the queen maybe but b7 pawn is
just loose definitely hanging and now the d
files open did not like that decision because now
you can't you still can't move the bishop or you
still can't you know you can you play b6 but that
does weaken many squares and the d file is open c6
that's usually a good structure c6 and e5 is kind
of an annoying structure it really is as an e4
player i hate playing against that structure a lot
because of the center control it does even though
it's not in the center but it is in the center
like it's not yeah if you look at the bishop
on c4 and the knight on a3 neither of them
can really access these important squares
the knight on a3 is just sad it's really
annoying it's a very good move by the way so
very annoying just so you guys know if you
ever want to have a nice structure like that
pawns on c6 and e5 are very nice in the philidor
the pierce type defenses and things like that very
annoying so knight to c2 we had to kind of do that
and yeah he needs to get the knight in the game
somehow queen eight three or queen a2 he's gonna
be two yeah he played b4 but this is ugly i just
don't have any squares like man chris is doing
a great job restricting you tonight one thing
carissa has done well uh this whole match actually
got to give her credit is the bishop pair i think
she's utilized the bishop here so well in fact the
game she disconnected sadly was a bishop hair game
that's why she was executing super well yeah she's
doing very good very good here the bishop pair is
awesome she does castle queen side now there is
knight before assuming a6 but you still don't have
a clear plan like it's just c6 and e5 oh now okay
that that that i'm feeling great about is white
the e5 pawn's gone we good we're good appreciate
it like thanks right and that's so i think you
maybe have to take that but that knight c2 knight
d4 can always come in and suddenly suddenly you're
right back in there hey so what is it what is
it amman that was not a move obviously and the
engine went crazy what you thinking well knight
c5 and like take bishop e6 and like some sort
of take and queen f7 it's it's getting close to
to winning so i'm taking like queen g8 queen f7
it's almost winning on the spot i almost sacked
too i almost sacked on d7 but then i was like well
we do have bishop e6 first so that's better oh
beautiful play here from teddy yikes man the thing
is look at this structure from teddy it's so solid
and meanwhile black's position is falling apart
so she's really yeah really strong it looks like
you can stack on c3 guys but the intention is
actually after captures you play knight c2 and it
defends everything and we're up a piece no more
checks actually either we cover all the checks
as well so you got to be very careful here rook
d7 is scary because you do have to keep the back
rank on there there it is it's kind of the last
shot here takes knight c2 and now we have uh uh
really checks and barrages of checks rick d's
i mean uh maybe not yeah rook d7 rook h1
at least stays alive yeah uh queen takes a
five he just takes a point yeah so i i think king
a8 rook b8 is the correct way to try um still of
course shouldn't work but d4 is okay yeah queen
d4 defend everything yeah defend everything this
is a time scramble so i don't know who's going
to win this it should be it should be right it
should be teddy what we're going to see here guys
it's a time scramble and teddy should win this but
we're not that sure charis is playing some tricky
moves and vertigate's a threat yeah ricky it's a
real threat king you two i'm out of the way rook
the eight oh my goodness oh you gotta play nike
she missed it she missed the mate it was
right oh my goodness everything i wanted
in life you gave it to me and it was not i
couldn't finish oh man bro queen d2 is made
in one and she tried to play on for the win and
she had to win and now it's no more win she got
a draw though i think she wanted it you got two
seconds she got yeah she gonna take the draw
no she she's two man she never takes a draw
i mean she don't believe in it this might
work out for her though this might work
out rookie two is greedy five queen d3
game over queen d3 i'm out the way how is it
oh my goodness teddy's mad i'll be mad too
if there's one person who who deserved you know
some good fortune in this match it was probably
carissa after everything she you know we said it
before it lives by the sword dies by the sword
and the sword is her being that's that stubborn
that young talented stubborn player you always
want to win you don't want to draw this game
she missed her chances for meeting one but
when the draw was on the table she said no i'm not
having this again i need to get back in the match
what do you make of things so
far as we head into the break
amazing i think it was crazy but we'll be
back after this so yeah stay with us guys
and we are going to get into the bullet portion
very very soon but first want to remind you guys
about some things upcoming first of all the uh
world corporate chess championship that's right
the first uh ever that i know of world corporate
chess championship coming to the feed day online
so it's an official feed event it's gonna be
happening online and that is gonna be taking place
in february so mark the dates on your calendar
uh you know james i was thinking about maybe
uh the chess bras uh you know myself eric uh
you know getting involved and just cleaning up
the corporate championship what do you think
i'm with it actually add me on that uh squad
as well absolutely i'll sign the chess brought
paperwork when y'all send it over and uh yeah
let's get it let's do it look to get candy on a
two-day contract and click clean up but there's
going to be uh google and the likes of the big
companies competing so that should be a lot of fun
and more on the streaming side we have arena kings
that is happening mondays and fridays there's a 20
000 prize fund so that's something to keep your
eyes on your favorite streamers are pretty much
always playing in that weekly uh myself over the
chess bras play at cantee you've seen him do some
commentary i know you play when you can uh james
but fun a fun tournament you know for for anybody
to try to win it's not like the same players
win every time the lower rated guys can still
get a win in there that is correct we're excited
for rainy kings you can play mondays and fridays
that's right and you know without further
ado there's lots of stuff happening at
chess.com so we want to make sure to let
you guys know about the upcoming events but
the most important upcoming event right now is the
bullet portion of this match james i mean one plus
one we've been speculating you know who might be
the favorite going in but how do you feel just
maybe about the momentum of these players going
into this match momentum wise teddy definitely
has a huge momentum here uh charissa yip is like
i gotta win i have to play i have to get in the
zone basically and sometimes you go into a zone
where you just run off games no matter who's in
front of you so that's what karissa yipp needs
to go into that moment or spend some time in
the hyperbolic chamber right now and actually
uh do her thing and come out very strong so
let's see what happens here one second increment
they're using the same openings too same stuff
bishop f5 a new move from teddy i think you
did queen b8 last time so slightly different
here and you know we'll see what they have
prepared but that plus one does change it
you know a player who's uh used to playing online
uh they play one minute with zero seconds right
right so that one second it really does throw off
those bullet players who think you know oh it's
bullet i'll just clean up in that section um but
that's not the case at all exactly here and bullet
of course is that one second increment it's still
bullet chest and when you get to five six seconds
that one second doesn't help as much as you think
it does so here you want to be very smart with the
time here teddy is down 10 seconds and then in
bullet that's a lot of time that lays down a lot
of time being down 10 to 12 seconds already here
with white having pretty easy position i would say
i see g4 g5 coming quickly getting the king out
of the way on b1 she's taking his extra pawn i'm
liking white's position already this is what
carissa needs quickly easy positions to play
which gives you nice moves and nice play so it's
not too tactical where you have to spend so much
time with the accuracy parts yeah and and uh i'm
wondering about trading queens because i almost
feel like if you keep the queens on the board
that oh bishop b5 though that force is a queen
tree that's a strange i think that's a strong
movement whoa 93 that's not a move get him off the
board oh my goodness teddy that's a bad
thing for him oh man teddy ain't ready
oh man teddy not ready he wasn't ready for it
queen defense i think carissa is feeling good
starting off this uh this board rook one and
yeah she should clean up this game up 15 seconds
plus 10 on the board right and he and a smart
advantage or a smart uh way to keep playing
for teddy is just keep the clock running keep the
clock running so you have to play every game out
no resignations every game should be played
out to its entirety until the clock runs out
and rookie seven is going to happen takes and
queen d6 yeah it's pretty easy yeah yeah this
is out here this is out just making moves
it's kind of hurt like when you know you're
just getting crushed and you're like well i
just got to keep moving because of the time
like i'm getting crushed right now but i'm just
going to keep playing here that's always a tough
situation when you're getting destroyed and you're
just sitting there and hoping it's over soon yep
that's all that's going on right now and uh teddy
knows that he's mark look at him sitting and
stalling too like he knows what he's doing right
now yeah it's very smart and then all you just
got to keep it keep the clock running what a smart
man teddy's over here getting crushed but i'm just
gonna take my time i'm gonna take my absolute
here my absolute he has a four game lead and
he's thinking match strategy he's saying uh you
know hmm i'm really gonna have seven and this is
good stuff too like he's trying this no there's no
still man in there that was a nice check gg there
wow yeah and a big start for carissa yet it's now
eight and a half to five and a half only a three
game lead uh for teddy coleman here and carissa is
surging if we're talking momentum i'm saying look
carissa has got to be absolutely satisfied with
what's happened in the last couple games a big
win at the end of the three minute portion and
a fantastic start to the bullet absolutely after
that last win there it was awesome for her she's
in the element here this is a better king's indian
it looks like for both of them actually i think
they played this pretty well already this city
seems pretty good usually the knight this is a
way to play i do know king's indian theory here
is the knight over from d7 to b6 you also have
the knight eight seven ways where you're going
to break with f6 uh eventually here but this is
more attacking like i'll do like the 97 ip6 myself
here so let's see look what teddy did he did
knight h3 and brought the knight to f2 thank
goodness you know that knight is not staying on
h3 the whole game oh man thanks teddy huge oh my
goodness it's game over oh she's swinging hey hey
tapped him on the shoulder he turned around and
she hit him as hard as he could and he drops he's
dropping wow that's another one karissa yip is
turning up now okay she came to play you know she
came to play you cannot count her out of this one
absolutely no i think this is anybody's match
right now wow 20 minutes left and we're good we
have a crazy match unfolding right check out
the check out the bullet ratings actually i
just noticed that teddy's not he doesn't be you
know maybe he doesn't play that much bullet but
he that's a difference that is the difference and
it's slightly showing right now slightly showing
what i remember is that teddy played levy and what
was crazy was levy you know levi's rating and boy
i mean so much higher than teddy's but teddy
held his own in the bullet portion so again
i don't think he's i don't think he plays that
much but you just can see like he's capable of
just hanging with uh the very best so hanging with
that bullet is uh scary very scary levy and bullet
but uh here i mean dang just like he's must be
hanging out he's not hanging with this one no
not this one he's just hanging with this one guys
oh man yeah this is uh this is amazing amazing
she has to keep it up if you have
four there's 20 minutes left with only
two if she she finishes off it will be
only two points yeah will she come back
so the important thing for me right here is she
needs to just move that bishop on a g7 if you
don't use that piece you don't really feel your
advantage and finally there she goes it doesn't
matter about the pawn it's more you just need to
get that bishop into the game absolutely great
great point you just have to get the bishop into
the game because like it's queen tonight versus
queen and light square bishop because the dark
square bishop's just chilling over there and also
f6 should should be played it should have been
played already but f6 is fine now 58 now bishop
that's beautiful queen b6
he's trying to keep up the time though the very
smart play from um from teddy here as the clock
runs out he will be the victor here if it ends
right now so he needs to to keep the clock running
yeah just bishop b3 or bishop d3 here there's
lots of mates on the board nicely done nicely
another win yes he's swinging chris fighting
back fighting back just like that and here's e4
e5 okay and we got a vienna she's
gonna hit him with that gambit
she loves that stuff [ __ ] oh she didn't this
time is it f4 now oh she didn't do it at all
really that's interesting i remember her playing
a lot of early f4s this one's very early though
this one's yeah this one's too early but she
takes that f4 i like this vienna she plays
yep solid solid opening wow
okay a3 a6 knight f3 knight in many cases
knight g4 is knight g5 so bishop g4 was played
i haven't played this in a while yeah 92
i used to play vienna a little bit yeah
so that so basically bishop takes um two
bishops for white now queen h4 the idea
for teddy and that means you can't really hang
on to that bishop you can't go like bishop d2
because queen h4 comes in quick as a flash so um
bishop pair is not in carissa's hands anymore but
i mean he can't really hate on the position board
position i like knight f4 here well actually
knight d4 but that knight is really strong on f4
uh oh she had an xc3 for knight d5 same intention
but i had two choices even h5 or d5s in
some cases so that was the the intention
there g3 is very weak yikes very very
annoying move queen g5 i mean e3's an idea
knight d4 i don't know um i'm definitely liking
blacks to counter play here black's definitely
all in the position here i can't castle my dark
squares aren't mine hang on oh that's the rap yeah
that's a wrap snap snap have a good day that's
over yeah this is not how you play the queen g2
queen g2 and then knight takes f3 king d1
and they have good that's what check flex
real hard oh but you remember knight f3 there's
there's 95 and rook f1 this could be a blunder
yeah you actually right i forgot about rook f1
hitting f7 and knight d5 you're actually right bro
oh 95 is good oh takes takes am i getting the same
wow good play here good play good play for both
sides i think black's gonna end up just a little
bit ahead but um carissa can't have done any
better yikes he getting both the pawns over there
can you just wait oh h6 yeah that works same thing
the same idea i'll get tonight when i want
to yep get tonight when i want bishop d5 uh
rook b8 probably just get out of the pan but
that's that's very passive rick f8 i like it
i mean but not really good game so far by both
players there's tactics all over the place but
uh it's actually wound up that the pawns are
even surprisingly if teddy loses this is three
games in a row do you notice that come on that's
three that's three in a row from carissa if he
loses this game and he's a favorite to lose it
we say it because he's down on time now this is
a time scramble but he got less time yeah bishop
to g4 very nice maybe bishop f5 clamping down
four seconds left for teddy here he has to move
faster he's just losing he's just growing yeah
she's gonna take this one i believe she's gonna
as long as she doesn't blunder away her life
he takes c4 he's good i think white spawns
move faster than black spawns here c5 d5
oh yeah those center pawns you're correct c5
oh you want to advance the dark squares right
oh king e5 right uh wow here it was made oh my
goodness e5 this is d6 mate or bishop uh c3 yikes
king d3 uh did we just no i don't take that
don't take that okay this should be i think
this should be winning for black but she
had to play a4 a3 there's a big chance there
oh snap nope she's good bishop b6 that was
cheering six was needed yeah [ __ ] should
be six well not bishop e7 yeah that was
that even think about the other move
is this winning is this gg oh this is definitely
winning oh my goodness game over because the
bishop is gonna go to b6 queen check queen check
with check what check clean what are you doing
queen oh my goodness what is this yes still
winning okay king b7 and push the pawn up yeah
oh my goodness and i move the bishop out of
there and teddy is gonna win this game wow and
he needed to breathe you see him breathing oh man
i was getting killed out there coach hey stop me
out coach sub me please sub me man it was like oh
man oh man that was tough she was playing so good
yeah well and this is something i'm honestly
surprised that she doesn't have internalized but
when you have opposite bishops if you have the
light squirt bishop and your opponent has a dark
square bishop when you have pass funds you advance
them on the opposite color of your bishop and that
is just that's just the rule so when she played
d5 the the black uh king and bishop went in on
the blockade and it was over for the rap yeah
but anyways we're on to the next game and that's
how quick bullet moves uh carissa already to me
this opening is working well against teddy's uh
weirdness eddie center yeah i'm liking it right
i'm liking it as well and bishop c4 yeah great
move here i mean pressure on the file or the
diagonal so we argue yeah castle is correct
we are giving up e3 oh that's kind of weird by
the way yeah yikes yeah this isn't good no more
it's not looking too good no more not at all
the rookie 8 is nice though because you hit the
knight and the bishop behind it is being hit
everything is hanging almost basically yeah
there's so many so takes takes and then bishop f5
and we live okay knight around and oh i'm second
nah never mind queen takes e3 check i was gonna
sack on f5 oh you might have to though maybe yes
so this is this means the f7 pawn is hanging but
knight a5 looks strong is bishop seven the move
yes it is he found it dang good stuff teddy takes
takes g4 that's what it is man boy tactics man
yeah i hope you did your puzzle rush today in the
chat i hope you did you puzzle rush so that's
exactly what this is but a lot of bullet is
puzzle rush when you get these kind of positions
take on f7 if queen takes we traded queens play g4
right so a5 is hanging rick f8 is a move so
what about knight c f8 looks great yeah cafe
oh but it's a lot of stuff hanging yeah so many
things are hanging here a lot of stuff hanging
g4 oh right and you see him like can i just play
g4 that's exactly what he said can i just play g4
bro he just did it and he plays it there it is g4
okay but you know 16 seconds that king wide open
this is anyone's game in my opinion uh
yes anyone's game absolutely anyone's game
absolutely even though i'm getting this
what wow does that work that does work
rick takes c7 i mean what are we thinking
about and then so if that knight gets attacked
like bring the rook back from d5 right oh
nice we're taking and those bishops can
still be dangerous here i gotta get rid of
one of them now oh yeah king f2 i was gonna
play knight f6 but that hangs a pawn i was
trying to get rid of one of those knights
oh my god bishop d4 bishop d4 oh you missed it
yeah you're right though bishop d4 was nasty
that was hard not that it's hard to see but man
that was a sequence right there this is rick b2
rick b2 yeah what do you do rick c1 okay he's
going to take the file rook c3 probably try to
get out of this pin with king e1 or king
d1 better move getting closer take take
carissa is everything that gets this way
too i gotta yeah she's doing everything
three to four seconds here on the clock
yo oh my goodness three to four seconds
bishop b4 maybe she's gonna go the king's too
close now dang yeah check no mating sequences
that was not that good i don't think she
should have no mating sequences here come
the pawns but i'm not sure if it's in time
it's just a it's just a straight race here
look at the time for teddy you move with 0.2
seconds oh my gosh echoing the clock flex your
heart move the knight out of the way okay try
to oh she just forgot oh my god it's over no
no so right now i'm looking at the overall match
clock and i'm saying look if you're carissa it's
now you win every single game and that's the only
avenue to victory you have to win every single
game you have to win every single game you have
to so nerve-racking those time scrambles when it's
like zero point and you're like oh my god just
make a move just put something on the board yikes
that rook check oh man it was so hard this is the
hardest part right here this is always the hardest
part of the match is the bullet portion yeah yikes
so i i do not think it's over yet i think there is
maybe just enough time uh for for four victories
yeah she's gonna have to basically yeah but the
thing is she's gotta get three victories and then
even if the last game starts with one second on
the game clock it still counts it still counts
yeah you're right yes so there is enough time
guys there really is but carissa has simply got to
win this game and there's no way around it there's
no way around it correct knight takes h4 wow we
already have something new here not familiar with
this one yeah taking pawns i'm a pawn grabber
as well yeah i was going to say f5 what okay
uh that's dynamic like who would you like i'm not
actually sure who would i want in this position
yet i'm not so i'm look if you need to win a
game i like the fact that it's in balance it's
messy who cares if you're carissa you're happy to
get this right that's correct that's like castle
hitting e4 long castle yeah yeah i'm getting out
the way have a nice day castle queen side other
side of civilization put the rooks on g1 whoa
that's a little scary you could always take that
anyway like the bishop was ben i don't think
that was necessary right now yeah you have to
get the king out of the center castle queen side
and then you f3 was actually even a better move
bishop takes e4 i would never play that teddy
what are you doing he he's saying that to
himself too what am i doing i'm not myself right
now that's exactly right takes h5 takes h5 yep
and carissa is just trying to throw every pawn off
the starting square doesn't care look at that e5
just sacrificing i mean look at this kind of
chest today bishop c5 and we live it looks
like we're crushing but it's not it's running yeah
it's crazy but that king is running that's crazy
sometimes chess is a miraculous game bishop b6
is a real threat broke a6 oh [ __ ] should be six
anyway and then he plays king ca so we're good
to go great movie teddy so maybe yeah queen b6
queen b6 and just probably castle queenside it's
you have done this too much your king has been
sitting here it's way too long yeah yeah i think
that's fair rick takes a two king b-1 king b-1
yeah king b-1 get out of the way and then we're
going to team a4 though queen a4 is tricky oh
that's mate huh bishop a3 then needed and play big
move and then c5 queen c5 after uh rook takes a3
fantastic find that should be it and she needs
that there it is there it is hitting him in
his lip wow hitting him back swinging back just
like that look at her work she's doing some work
here guys let her work now of course teddy is very
smart with the clock here he needs to keep working
the clock he needs to keep working the clock here
because carissa is on fire she's she's definitely
catching some heat here and she's ready but the
time you want hanging it's not her friend yeah
he wants hanging queen to be three that's a win
on time that's huge he could have prolonged that
game for a long time a long time yeah wow it's a
three-game match good job carissa three-game match
she keeping it very close here six remember
it's just two wins just just need two wins
then you start that third game and there's
at least a chance yeah you're so right yeah
two wins from her she needs to give everything
she's got here everything she's got it has to be
this opening has been working online yeah this
has been working yeah big fan of this opening
something like takes and i mean it's knight takes
e5 it means bishop b5 of c6 i don't think this is
really that dangerous yeah at all actually castles
i mean kind of an even game white has an isolated
pawn in the center i mean it's easy plans when
you have the isolated pawn strategically you have
a plan already put the knight on d5 trade pieces
and put the heavy zone into the files that's it
uh so you don't even think about this i'm starting
to wonder why didn't carissa play this uh the
whole game the whole match sorry yeah right the
whole match yeah it's a great setup and it's worth
every single time that's right that's right
this could be a whole different game here
a whole different match a whole different match
there we are just put the rooks on the file with a
smile rookie a rook d8 and just kind of chill and
you know improve the position slowly yeah that's
it this is strategically one but you it's you
know also could be drawn as well but many times
one thing i think the bigger issue is that if this
is winning for carissa it's not gonna be winning
for a while you know like it's going to be a it's
going to be a grind so i think she's playing well
but teddy is saying look i need to run this
clock down there's five under five minutes left
if i get a grindy game where i might be a little
bit worse but hey um you know it's milk the clock
milk the clock yeah milk the clock here queen to
c4 and yeah i think b6 might have been a mistake
there because the c6 is weak now so and that's the
pressure is now gone and yeah we're doing good as
y here uh teddy's doing so great look how quick
she's playing though to her credit uh whether
she's playing the best moves or not look at the
time he's down to 14 seconds this is exactly
what she needs to do she needs to play as fast as
humanly possible that's right as fast as humanly
she's playing really fast too like 37 she's been
up a lot of time here i mean she's definitely
showing some strength here and bullet definitely
showing some straight than bullet like wow i
mean great performance here um regardless even
after the slips we've had and the issues today
she has uh made it pretty a pretty close match
still mm-hmm knight to c3 coming and rookie one
rookie one night one yeah that is the nastier
movie oh you see that won nicely three minutes
he chopped out beautiful or she was like nah i'm
not standing there bro i'm not about to stay in
there okay knight d2 you know she's not taking
the draw i mean even when she was losing him
all right i mean come on d5c man rookie i can
just take that can't i it's so close to me
i probably don't want to take it but just
capture it like why not whatever take take
but look at the time running down it's
three minutes 30 seconds and after this game
it's looking like it's only one more that's
tough right there and she still hasn't won this
game yet that's that's still in the it doesn't
look like she is going to win this one either
day based off of uh play now rookie two was a
shot or uh it was checked so we couldn't do that
it doesn't look like either side's gonna win
this so i mean of course yeah this bullet we
don't know yeah we don't know what's about to
happen right now but it looks like black is
doing fine but white's doing okay too check
knight before knight c6 take on a7 yeah and
now now rookie two there we go black's doing
well yeah knight takes and just clean up on the
the bishop beats the knight here defending pawns
this is good stuff for carissa oh take those pawns
she's playing very well uh she's just basically
uh turning it on at the wrong moment you know
just a little bit earlier was needed that's it i
mean yeah teddy can yeah it's two minutes left man
that's like one she's got this win she's got this
win that's like one game she's like one game off
yep one game off rook g6 had pushed
the pawns he's gonna hide yeah
it's almost a minute now yeah
she's milking the clock here
great milking of the clock here no resigns
yep and and you know you wonder you know do those
30 seconds that he spent earlier in the match
during the clock does that matter well yeah it
looks down to it now it comes quite valuable yeah
it's quite valuable yeah that's a great match
strategy for even you know going forward for
people playing in these events just how to milk
the clock and use the time to your advantage maybe
using all of your time even in positions where
you're up maybe if you've got a two game lead
wait a while before you make the mate you know
stuff like that so this is this is a situation
where carissa nearly needs to pre-move the entire
match yeah there's a minute and a half left
and he's got a minute on his clock with
plus one second i think the match is over
especially with a guy like teddy who's so
conscious of that clock situation um i think
that that he is minimum going to win this match
by by a point here yeah he's uh yeah minimum by
a point yes to too gay i mean she made a comeback
for real if there was more time she the momentum
how was swinging she would have caught up i think
she would have caught up here the way to see
two moves yeah 56 under a minute guys under a
minute it's does not yeah this this game is way
too far away because i mean there's like 40
seconds on teddy's clock and there's nearly
40 seconds on the match clock so at some
point he can literally just wind it down um
plus he doesn't even have a bad position like
you know we're not even talking about that
yeah here you can honestly just chill and do
whatever here i remember in the last bullet game
with levy he promoted to an under promotion to a
knight it was actually pretty funny it was like oh
night it was like great it was a
great moment so here understanding
a great match strategy here from teddy
as he's going to walk away today's winner
yeah absolutely as we see that match clock slowly
dying on the hopes of carissa yip as she made an
incredible comeback and pretty much did exactly
what she needed to do in the bullet but uh maybe
just dropped too many games early on to the you
know the the queens that were hanging and the
clock situation and the disconnects a few things
didn't go her way because the bullet is i mean
we've just seen a whole different character man
this is not the same carissa that came in today
when this bullet she just came and showed
every bit of the 2457 rating right now
which is uh man she's a force to be reckoned with
and that is officially we just announce it for
everybody that that is officially the last match
uh sorry the last game of the match of the one
minute portion and of the entire match so um it
is going to be uh it is going to be over ggs ggs
carissa of course they're going to
finish this game i mean carissa can
bring this back to a very respectable one
you know one game difference with a win here
one game difference i mean extremely close match
here one game difference here it all came down
to the bullet section luckily if it wasn't for
teddy being up four games i mean this could be
the other way this could have went
the other way it was even for a while
then he got up to four games and but
if it was even going into the bullet
right now she would be up she would be up right
now winning the match full credit to teddy i mean
uh and that is gonna be a win by timeout i
don't think teddy he's gonna be too upset when
he realizes or probably already knows the match
is officially over uh he has one so it's ten and
a half to 90 and a half and as i as i said she's
going to bring the match back to within one game
james and i mean now that we're at the end of it
all that the heart rate is starting to settle down
any final thoughts before we get into the
interviews oh man i think it was a great match
i think uh the blitz portion there was of course
mistakes as all chess has there was mistakes teddy
was just proving better in the blitz he was just
playing better and making the better moves and
blitz and of course uh in the bullet carissa
yipp definitely turned it on she turned it on
but i think it was a little bit too late at that
point yeah and that's that's a pretty good summary
honestly um we are going to see if we can get the
players uh around for a post-match interview which
is staple at the end of these i am not a gm events
um so congrats to teddy coleman he comes with the
victory today but myself james i will be joined
by the players hopefully right after this so stick
around
and welcome back myself and mr canty
here are joined by the players we have
teddy coleman and carissa yep uh
here for the post-match interview
teddy a wild match you know it actually came
down to 10 and a half to nine and a half
you looked like in that final portion that
you were maybe checking the game clock was
that something you were very conscious
of as carissa was mounting a comeback
yeah no absolutely i was checking it from time to
time because um i remember my match against danny
last year i went into the bullet up four games
also and he forced an armageddon so i was like oh
my god especially after i lost the first two games
i was like oh my god please don't happen again
and so you know obviously carissa just played
so much better than i did in the bullet so i was
i was lucky to survive that one yeah i mean
the the match clock is part of it as well and
and carissa i i do not take pleasure in reminding
you about these things but there are a lot of
games that you probably wish you had back there
were some queen hangs there was like some missing
taking back a queen and then also the disconnect
i mean you played so well in the bullet do you
think back on some of those games as maybe where
you could have had the chance to win this match
i mean yeah i ended up being really close and
like right now i'm just thinking only didn't play
like rick f3 and actually took back the queen
because i was getting like super stressed and
i thought he was gonna play like rookie one or
something he missed i had rick f went after it and
then he took the queen but my mouse was already
like on the rook and i was trying to take the
queen back that's what it meant and that didn't
happen so yeah yeah no that's exactly what i was
saying at the time but man yeah yeah i think that
also happened to me in the game when uh i think
i had like rook rook checkmate but instead like
i because i didn't think you were gonna allow
it so i had my rook like hovering over the
the pond to take it and then you queened and i
took it anyway and i was like oh my gosh oh yeah
yeah and teddy you're ever the animated player so
it's in moments like that that we can all visually
see exactly what's going on like you're hovering
rook a2 you actually take rook a1 the evaluation
bar goes from made in one back to 0.00 and i mean
was it was this a crazy match for you in terms of
the emotional side of things yeah no i definitely
am a very emotional player and something that
robert house likes to make fun of me a lot for
um and yeah i think it just totally shows and
i think chris on the other hand just kind of sits
there cool as a cucumber so i probably could take
a few pointers from you on that solo facade i
mean trembling shaking on the inside you know
james and i couldn't tell i can say that
yeah we couldn't tell what worked well for
you karissa in the bullet portion you were
going crazy actually we felt that you were
just we saw another carissa in the bullet
here what worked well for you in the bullet
i mean i guess like well i feel like first of
all teddy is a lot better at blitz than bullet
and um i guess at that point i was just
trying to like make moves as quickly as
possible like sometimes when i overthink things
the move i end up playing is just not as good
so yeah i feel like i do better in bullet than
blitz usually excellent that's a fair assessment
there's actually one uh of your openings that
i wanted to ask you because based on the games
that i saw i don't think teddy was handling your
g6 bishop g7 e6 knight e7 set up very well and i
was thinking like man what if carissa played this
the whole match um did you did you feel like that
because the openings you were getting looked
tremendous especially in the bullet section
um yeah i mean i'm pretty comfortable in the
king's indian and like this g6 e6 thing is a
thing that my friend taught
me shout out to craig hilby
yeah i usually like it's not very sound so i tried
to play it in like bullet time controls i'm pretty
sure teddy would have found a better way to
handle it if i played it more in the glitch
right yeah i don't know i honestly was not super
prepared for it and you yeah i honestly felt like
in general when i had the white pieces you were
just completely out playing me like almost every
single king's indian ended up being bad for me you
know i tried to play some of these lines where i
just played like hey you know d4 knight f3 bishop
g5 or bishop f4 and those weren't going well so
yeah i don't know i think i got a
lot to think about after this one
one of the yeah that's a good point that's what
prep looks like you're gonna have to come into
the next match thinking about these things that
that uh maybe chris has uncovered in this match
one of the things that i noticed about karissa
and so much credit to her for this is that never
give up style is like when there's a draw on
the board carissa it's not even registering to
her that it's there she's always thinking about a
way to play on and sometimes she would lose a game
from that but there were a lot of examples where
she won a game at the critical moment i mean teddy
what do you think about that style of you know
you almost expect her to play on in every position
yeah i mean look i think in the whatever 20 games
i think we only had one draw which is crazy um
and you know i i mean coming into this match i was
honestly also just pretty nervous because someone
like carissa is already like incredibly talented
and only getting better every day and um you know
yeah i think she had great you know just great
fighting spirit and every game was a slugfest and
yeah definitely you know like we talked
about earlier i was definitely feeling
the heat and feeling the stress in it
okay i was i was really stressed too
we can do definitely not uh james and i
were we were thoroughly entertained um
i mean looking forward in the uh in the bracket
teddy i mean you've you've come away with the win
today you're playing against uh lars oscar houg in
the next uh match as per the bracket i mean um not
something you've given any thought to yet i'm sure
taking it one match at a time but um any plans
for going into the next round in terms of what you
might do differently yeah um you know i think last
year when i played this um you know i lost pretty
badly to elena she crushed me and so seeing lars
um i think he won like six or seven in a row in
the bullet against delena um i know i probably
need to just practice a ton of bullet otherwise
i think i'm in big big big trouble yeah gotcha
gotcha well that was a an exciting match to be
sure it ended up being just a single game so
um i i felt that that was an incredibly close
match and just a little bit extra time in the
bullet and who knows carissa gets another game
and that dreaded armageddon that uh that you were
scared of teddy might have happened but uh big
congrats uh teddy for your match victory today
carissa we're sorry it didn't go your way you
know the disconnection as well um nothing seemed
to be going your way this match but uh we were
thoroughly entertained and i think i speak for
the chat james and myself that your style of chess
is like super entertaining very aggressive style
tactical we just had a a lot of fun commentating
this match today thanks guys we really appreciate
it thanks good luck teddy thanks thanks guys and
that is uh it's going to conclude today's match
james we have the bracket on the screen there
as players uh moving on to the next round you
can see they've advanced uh teddy is one of those
players and we've already talked about some of the
other first round matchups james and you were
hinting at some of them that caught your eye
actually absolutely well of course now i'm
definitely interested in that teddy coleman
lars oscar match of course because he's what he
said teddy's correct like he has to improve his
bullet here as lars is i think he's 2 700 in both
at least i think yeah blitz and bullets so he's uh
super super strong so teddy has a lot of uh a lot
up for um for grabs for him but eric rosen cigar
i'm not really familiar with uh cigar yet but
eric rosen of course we know is super strong here
and gostia and tanya that's going to be a nice
matchup there i don't know who's a favorite there
yeah no so those are the upcoming matches i'm not
a gm continues of course we also have arena kings
i want to make sure you guys are uh keeping track
of everything chess.com is hosting here there's so
many things upcoming so we have lots more of these
commentary uh commentary i am not a gm but twenty
thousand dollar prize find arena kings you know
the top streamers that you all know about hikaru
we've seen uh we've seen you know the the likes
of levy and just all those big streamers you guys
like to follow you know chess brawls get in there
from time to time candy himself so prize is up for
steak uh up up for grabs rather and it's just a
really fun tournament to play and watch no matter
what your rating is so mondays and fridays tune
in to arena kings and what about pogchamps three
james that that i mean we just got so many things
to remind people of presented by grip6 the the
players that are competing in pogchamps i mean you
might recognize some of them from the streaming
world but the most interesting thing is bringing
in the people from outside we have code miko
the tuber we also have people from so many
different disciplines like daniel negrano
over playing poker and coming in playing some
chess we also have rayne wilson uh ludwig logic
you mentioned the the decorated rapper that he is
just so many exciting people um of all sorts of
backgrounds competing in this uh james absolutely
and mr beast too of course a youtube monster just
uh blowing up everything in youtube right now
having him is just uh it's awesome guys and this
is only just the beginning yeah absolutely and
one of the uh more interesting and unique events
on the calendar is actually the feed eight online
corporate uh championship so this is happening uh
february 19th 21st um take note of that but that's
going to be pretty exciting and you mentioned to
me james that you know even the powerhouse of
google has has signed up there so we're just
waiting to see the full list of companies that
are going to participate but that should be kind
of a unique event where you get to see uh you know
which company has the best chess players on offer
that's gonna be fun to watch actually i'm
gonna check that coverage too i'm watching paul
champs i'm watching arena kings i'm playing like
we're doing everything guys and you want to get
involved too chat this is was just for you yeah
and i mean just just mark your calendars because
you don't want to miss any of these things there's
so many things going on that chess.com is hosting
and it's going to be live commentary as always
um you know it doesn't matter what the team is
chess.com has always got the the best of the best
whatever duo there's gonna be um hopefully you and
myself get to work uh together again in the near
future james because it was a uh it was a pleasure
today that was a really fun match tons of tactics
i had a great time it was great man i had a great
time too great time with the chat great chess it's
just all great right here at chess.com man come on
what are you talking about you know it's great
i love it and we're going to keep the action
going because i think we're going to be sending
the raid off to anna chess anna rudolph and i
think she's doing a lesson a coaching session with
michelle carr who's just on that pog champs three
uh introductory list of participants they're
doing a coaching session in preparation for
pogchamps three so that's where the raid is going
congrats to teddy coleman james any last words for
the people out there do you puzzle rush guys do
you puzzle us every single day go on chess.com
learn puzzle rush and have a nice day there
you go take care guys and thanks for watching
you